i wanted to buy like those luxury like
fruit gift boxes to bring today is that
why you asked me what my favorite fruit
is
okay
why didn't you bring my my favorite
fruit because i do i guess luxury
bananas aren't a thing
because i saw a box of cherries for like
200 and i just walked out 200.
all right welcome to this episode of
trash taste once again with the boys
scott and joey and today emily marichu
last week we had daidus and now it's
time for emily yeah yes hello
what do i say
hello
hello thank you for coming on today i've
spoken
honestly how tired connor was before he
just started like speed running man he's
like
you know connor's tired when he hosts
because his intro is always like what is
it
like i am the speed yeah
yes
so emily do you want to introduce
yourself to our audience just in case
they don't know who you are hi my name
is emily i have the channel emerychu uh
i just moved to japan a month ago you
and i'm a new member of geeksplus yeah
boy
welcome to the family
um so i guess why
what and why first question everything
why are you gay yeah why are you here
why'd you come to japan
so we're gonna go way back to like late
2019 right way back way back you guys
were actually well
we just moved yeah you too yeah we're
just about to move to japan yep and i
remember
uh
you me and didus were talking yeah we
were like we gotta come visit you in
japan when you move it'll be amazing
we're gonna put tickets as soon as we
get home
so we book tickets for 2020 and we're
like all right we want to visit japan
and see connor it'll be great yeah and
then covet happened and uh
it kept happening
and it don't stop coming
i think around 2021
uh
yeah i think 2021 yeah yeah connor was
like hey would you guys be interested in
actually like moving to japan yeah and
that sounded like you know i'm not an
idiot that's a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity i can't turn that down
sounds like a moment or something like
knocking on a door would you be
interested in moving to japan and
joining joining the culture
it's kind of like
the church
yeah i was in like the middle where it's
like i can't like be like yeah you can
come here but i can be like i can ask
you and i can ask maylene i'm like is
this something that you would be
interested in if so i'll be like merlin
these guys are good bring them over yeah
and then that kind of happened yeah yeah
so initially uh i was like well i want
to visit first yeah because i've never
lived outside of the country before yeah
i wanna you know like test the water so
have you ever been to japan before uh
yes actually a few years ago i visited
japan on like a guided tour so i don't
know if that counts but like it was for
a few days it was in osaka right okay
but that was like my last memory right
how old were you again
i was
23 24. okay okay not when you're like a
child or something like that no no no no
no because you made that yeah like i had
no memories it made it sound like you
were like five
you know when you yeah any place with
your parents yeah it's your parents like
you can't have like a black i mean i
love my parents
but record your parents boring yeah no
okay i'm calling your parents out like a
guided tour it was supposed to be a
mother-daughter trip right but my dad
gets major fomo
like he gets major fomo but he also
loves to complain all right so cute we
were like no i don't want like you're
gonna complain i already know you're
gonna complain the whole time
i just want this to be me and mom yeah
he's like no i want to come too and
you're like okay fine
and guess what he did the whole god
complain
i remember he went to kyoto we fed deer
in nara
um
see i haven't done that that would have
been a lovely memory tonight i've done
that no why
no it's like it's kind of far isn't it
how many times a lot but normally i'm
kind of enjoying the nightlife for
something yeah what a fun time see
that's the part i didn't get to enjoy
that is like what osaka is it's just
like one big like drunk mess yeah yeah
but like basically you know what one
with all kinds of come visit that's what
we will do yeah
i'll go to
naruto yeah
there isn't a whole lot to do in nara
yeah but like that's probably the
biggest like you know it's it's vicious
though right they're [ __ ] vicious
apparently since there's no tourists
right they've become very aggressive
yeah
they haven't had nearly as many people
as they would normally get so now when
you bring food they're like full on
attack yeah yeah
it's so so it's fun though i mean that's
like a really aggressive love from the
deer like they were already aggressive
beforehand right like they'd like chew
on your like jackets and like [ __ ] i
remember witnessing it was so funny i
wish i recorded it but i remember
witnessing this like
old japanese woman and like my dear was
trying to eat her bag because it's
something she's like fighting with it it
was so funny
also that sounds like conor's worst
nightmare because he's like [ __ ]
terrified of beers
i'm not scared of dears i just think if
they wanted to they could overthrow
humans you know
not those deers they're they're they're
like cutesy ones yeah they're the small
i mean the small they're small the ones
with like big ass [ __ ] antlers and
[ __ ] those ones that like they're like
that you see how far they jump
yeah you could say about that
so now that you moved it how does it
compare to like all your nun memories i
guess of like visiting here before well
i i feel like
because i was only here for what like
three four days well i was only in osaka
for like three years
i didn't even get to see a whole lot
right so you didn't even go to like
tokyo other than the airport no oh
really yeah oh that's an interesting
tool yeah so here was just completely
brand new to me right and it's been a
really good experience so far yeah i
holy [ __ ] it's just tea with rice no no
no
it's like it's rice
yeah jessica it's like a like think of
like a pokeball kind of okay right
you're obsessed with no that's not no
you you you're having the fancy
orchestras dude oh really yeah yeah yeah
like normally
did meline take you no
because normally ochazuke is literally
just like a you know a bowl of rice and
then you put green tea in it and you put
some foodie cookie on it and it's like
it's supposed to be like a breakfast
food no mine had like
sand that's the fancy [ __ ]
like dude flavored potato salad on the
side no no no no you're not gonna get
that like the flavor of the potato salad
that's good i've never even heard of
that
yeah that's all like you know at my
grandma's place she'd just be like
here's some rice he's a [ __ ] thing of
tea
breakfast
i guess before we get too much into
japan
we should probably like explain to the
audience more about you as well yeah i
want to know more about your yours
because they might not know what you do
so like what like on youtube you've been
doing what would you describe it because
dad has
yeah i like to illustrate uh stories of
during your time you know my life i like
to sure one place
i'm sorry say it just say it
i like to also have conversations with
my friends and draw
over that as well it's a lot of i just
draw that was a great good format that
really took off yeah because everyone
was telling stories and then i know
there's a few other people did like the
whole have a conversation anime yeah
yeah that really took off yeah i i those
are my favorite ones to work on yeah
just because they're always like it's
always the funniest
um yeah how did you get started yeah
when did you start
oh man okay i started shortly after i
graduated college right um
i graduated with a degree in elementary
education
and the next step was i had to publish
my credentials yeah i know right
i had to get my credentials to like be a
full-fledged t-shirt which meant like i
think like a year or half a year more of
schooling right i was really hesitant on
it because i was like i don't actually
want to be a teacher
right wait why'd you do that huh why'd
you do it because i
so i've always liked to draw but i
assumed that i was not ambitious or good
enough to like make a living off of it
oh that's so sad
it's not that sad it was just like well
i i don't think i have what it takes
like both i feel that's a like a mindset
and a dilemma a lot of artists have yeah
because it's like it's such a
competitive field so the moment you see
like one person who draws better you're
like [ __ ] everyone around me
i hate [ __ ] i can't compete with this
because like even i suffer from like
imposter syndrome but like there it's
like not on the same level as like
basically every artist i've met who just
like it's it's so hard for you guys from
what i you know i've talked to you guys
that like you guys see someone and it's
so hard for like you guys not trying to
mentally compare yourself to them
you know that you know
even if it might be like a completely
different style yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly i mean i don't i feel like i've
gotten to a point where i don't
automatically compare myself to other
artists yeah that's good it's more like
if they draw really good i'm like whoa
they draw really good whoa
now my dilemma is i'm worried of what
they think of me right right because as
an artist or as a person as an artist
there's so many artists that like are
amazing and they put their blood sweat
and tears into their art but like
it's the social media game for artists
it's like really hard so even if you're
super good yeah if you don't have that
like i guess little bit of luck yeah
yeah
and unfortunately like the rules of
social media is like skill is not like
it's it's not like a direct ratio to how
successful or how much engagement
artists will get on
youtube so like i know for a fact that
there's probably like artists out there
who are really good and they probably
look at my stuff and they're like
why the [ __ ] this is garbage how does
she how do you get i don't think anyone
does that have you ever done that to
someone else's art no
but
i know i i feel like it's very easy to
feel bitter when you work so hard and
yeah you don't see any progress yeah
yeah but i feel like if you're taking
that out by
you know being like oh why is this
person succeeding they're [ __ ] i feel
like that's
you're gonna have a bad mindset for
google yeah no it's a terrible mindset
but yeah yeah yeah but i guess something
you worry about yeah yeah cause i you
know when you're like the bigger you are
the more eyes that are on your stuff
yeah so there's you're always gonna have
people being like you don't deserve oh
of course of course i think that's true
in like almost like every creative
industry like even even youtube you know
where you know you see some very like
special youtubers yeah well you see some
very like very talented content creators
um and they have like [ __ ] 100 or
like 500 subscribers and then you see
like a lot of um a lot of other content
creators who get a lot of [ __ ] because
it's on the surface it might seem like
they don't put as much effort or they
might they might not make as much high
quality content but there's something
that also works about their content
because unfortunately arts is not just
to do with like your skill sets or how
skillful you are or how good of stuff
you make a lot of time to do to do with
marketing as well yeah and like how you
sell yourself yes it's marketing and
luck and those are like
like marketing especially is one thing
i've with i've met with a lot of artists
who are not the greatest that
unfortunately um and i'm just like you
know what i wish you knew how to market
yourself better because my god you got
you guys are so talented yeah yeah so
many people like that definitely yeah i
mean isn't like the fine art world just
like all marketing and hype essentially
because it's not it's like you just need
to get in the circles right your name
has to be put in those circles like like
hundreds of millions of dollars like all
right
yeah cause it's just like uh
like the moment you just got to know
your foot into
someone who you know once you know
someone who like owns a gallery or
something i feel it's a lot easier than
someone who's just you know painting in
their you know atelier and just like
hoping that someone will notice them one
day you know so you would
doing elementary school sorry no no
tangents are over very well
as long as one of us remembers where we
were it's okay gotta bring it back i
actually stopped drawing in college
i assumed i you know i'm not gonna use
this for work so right i'm not gonna
yeah and uh but obviously the whole time
secretly i really that was where my
passion you missed it you missed it yeah
and the moment i realized uh was
actually during like a big lecture hall
in my second semester of my senior year
there was a professor who was giving a
very passionate speech
um
and i remember she was like i have to
commend every single one of you that's
sitting here today because you're about
to enter a thankless field where you get
screwed over by the government you get
screwed over by administration you'll
get screwed over by parents and you
don't get paid [ __ ] for it but you're
doing it because this is your calling
and what you truly want to do
get me out of here
i was sitting there like wait no this
this wasn't this isn't my bad that's not
what i signed up for
i was like why oh that was like an
anti-awakening like
most people in lecture was trying to
sell you on the topic they're not just
like okay you're going to hate your life
you're going to regret everything like
damn you must really like kids
because i did like engineering because i
was like at least you make mad bank yeah
yeah yeah i mean i don't like it but i
would have paid a lot
why why
elementary school teaching i honestly as
you're like i got nothing else to do
it's because my parents were like oh
well i mean if you if you don't if you
can't do art uh just be a teacher
[Music]
why is that like the next like
progression oh you don't want to do
anything just teach [ __ ] kids they
were like you can draw for fun on the
side and i was like okay because i was
like 16 and i didn't know yeah yeah yeah
um yeah and so after i graduated uh one
of my friends gifted me a drawing tablet
um as a graduation present yeah it was
like you should draw again right and i
was like okay maybe yeah i will after i
graduate and then um i visited my
parents in korea and they live kind of
in the middle of nowhere so i had
nothing to do yeah so during that like
month i was there i just drew the entire
time and i was having so much fun right
like i wouldn't even leave like the
guest room that i was in my parents are
like hello are you okay go outside
you're in a foreign country
and uh
i ended up posting
like uh some videos it was honest it was
just like drawings to like songs right
and i put it on youtube you're like the
amv wasn't good enough so you're like
i'll make it myself
it's not good enough wasn't you drawing
to music or was it you like your
drawings edited to drawings edited to me
oh
basically drawing what was the song um
anyways what was the song what was the
so what was the song after uh
emily what's the song dude and by the
time
what is the song
what song is it
no i'm embarrassed well i mean we're
what is it emily um you know do you know
uh the song it's not like i like you by
static feet
it was cute i thought it was cute i won
that song that blew up and was
everywhere on youtube yeah
2015 that was
on youtube recommended plastered if you
watched any animated think like was it
2018. i think like 60 percent of
youtubers use that as their outro yeah
yeah like it was everywhere it's a cute
song
and i and i i drew to it and it did
really well surprisingly and uh i think
i posted like a work in progress version
because i was like maybe i'll finish it
yeah and then like a wave of people were
like finish it and i was like okay and
so i finished it and it did super well
and then i was like oh wow this is a lot
of fun super well what kind of what kind
of reviews are we talking about like how
many people were coming to this one
video that you put out
do you remember at the time yeah when i
got really excit like 100k
that's a law firm
i was in korea i was like whoa 100k
that's nuts 100k for first upload is
like ridiculous that is ridiculous your
first time using editing software as
well like this is
yeah and okay you know what's funny
so i i'm still really bad at using
editing software but i didn't even know
what the [ __ ] the dimensions for a
youtube video was
you're like guessing that's the black
part is on there
so like i've thought about like
recreating it
with like improved art
but also like people go to that video
thinking it's like a video from like
2012 and they're like 2018.
yeah so
uh by the time i
flew back home i think i had like 10 000
subs jeez oh my god from one video from
one video
while i was in korea i uploaded like
you do what a bunch
place what kind of stuff did you look
like it was it was still like songs are
just music all right
basically like unmonetizable stuff yeah
so just like youtube like no i could
monetize yeah youtube's just like
copyright claiming that [ __ ] like
would you watch a lot of youtube before
this or is it kind of like you kind of
casually watch casually okay okay okay
um
[Music]
yeah but i had a lot of fun i mean a lot
of my older videos i've unlisted now
just because like it embarrasses me to
see the art wait did you unleash the
league of legends impression one
uh
so one of my friends
what i'm so cool i'm like a stank-up
yeah yeah
emily emily did this league of legends
impression video it's so good one of my
friends
it's so funny now you're going to
explain it now you're going to explain
yeah it was back in like 2015 so what am
i
one of my friends uh then informed me
that i could monetize stuff on my
channel you're like what
yeah did you make money yeah they were
like have you ever considered like
monetizing your stuff and i was like you
can do what now like i've just been
doing this for fun well that's weird
because youtube normally like did you
know you can make money yeah immediately
yeah they're really really nice
especially if you get like 100k views
that's like just like oh do you want do
you want to make money turn on the
dollar sign emily turn it on
at that point i didn't even consider the
idea that i could do youtube full-time i
was like well this was fun i missed like
drawing i don't think anyone does right
they're just like oh i can make like 10
bucks here on there that's pretty sick
yeah yeah it's like pocket change yeah
the first time you see that graph go to
like five bucks you're like
i remember the first youtube paycheck i
got it was like 200 or something and i
remember like
running home from work and i was like i
got grocery money i'm so excited
um and yeah that's kind of how it
happened but i didn't tell my parents
for a while because i knew that if i
told them too early
they would try to discourage me right
yeah get that bang first yeah yeah yeah
yeah
where i'm where it's like i'm doing
youtube yeah oh but will it make you
money yes
you got to slap them with the fat stacks
before like they even question you right
yeah here's a grant
yeah here you go and they were like oh
okay
[Music]
i i was like with my parents when i
first started making money because we
were on vacation yeah back when i was 18
19 still and they were like made four
dollars
really that's insane how did you do that
like from the video like what how does
that work that's so like encouraging
because i was definitely on emily's side
i didn't tell my parents i was doing
youtube until like at least a year and a
half yeah my parents are just like
that's that's [ __ ] about it yeah for
me i was like parents i'll keep going
parent trade offer
white guy here
i quit my job and i give myself a year
and you get my love and support if i
succeed
i feel like it'd be different if my
original like degree was something more
like whoa i think that definitely helped
me a lot yeah
from like doctor to youtube
no no no because i think that's too much
in the other direction then i think i
think doctors like why would you throw
away the you put so much time into being
you definitely underestimate asian
parents though but like they wouldn't
let you not be a doctor once you are a
doctor yeah yeah yeah if you had like
computer science i'd be like that's
really good
like
could be i don't really understand it
though but i know what adoption is yeah
right right
come on like you know
that's true if once you're a lawyer
there's no way your asian parents are
going to be like you can't not be a
lawyer
that's what i've been telling everyone
like yeah lawyers are expensive yeah you
say that you're not a lawyer anymore
over my dead body
i think i think my funniest thing i've
heard about like asian parents is like
considering how much they want their
child to become a doctor they like to go
to the doctor
we would ever go to the doctor that's
exactly why they want their children to
be doctors so that they can just go to
their job
well you see my my parents knew that i
was not
like
smart enough to have to expect too much
from me right so i think for youtube
they were like oh you get to like do
that thing you've been doing you love to
do since you were like four yeah yeah
yeah [ __ ] okay sure good [ __ ] yeah go
for it
so like how did they react to you to be
like i don't want to be a teacher
anymore how did they react to you when
you fell out
you have to have that talk yeah well
yeah because they were like when are you
gonna take the exam like for your
credential program when you're gonna do
it and i was like i'm not gonna i'm
doing youtube
i have two hundred thousand at this
point i'd like tonight oh so you told
them that you were like quitting this
path when you said you were doing
youtube so yeah okay so i was like yeah
so you hit them with a double whammy
you're like i'm quitting this i'm doing
this now yeah and they were like well
because they didn't really understand
youtube that much so they were just like
what does that mean why would they
they're right yeah and they're like are
you making money and i'm like yeah and
they're like i mean you didn't know you
could make money when you first started
making videos how can you expect like
the elderly parents or all the parents
right yeah yeah so what kind of content
were you making after the
drawing amv's or whatever then because i
assumed league of legends impressions
league of legends impressions she plays
a lot of league
we played a lot yeah we played a lot of
league and i was in college
okay so impressions i think that'd be
fun i did it too
yeah
i'm also in the same cringey boat of
like doing it yeah yeah i was just i was
just like why why are you embarrassed
about conor i thought i thought like was
like were you animating connors videos
what was your very first was your very
first
video about like um
story time about like conventions or one
of them no that was like
what was the first first story that you
talked about the first story was it like
or was it like anime protagonist [ __ ]
like 101 no i think it was like artist
pet peeves
right what was the one where you did
like the ax someone stole your artwork
or something
someone else's like
2018
that was a little later down the line i
don't know when i when i got in touch
because i never saw you had twitter and
you didn't really use it at this point
yeah and you had like
1 000 followers but i saw your video
drawing and i was like oh i like that
video so i'll follow her and then i
think you followed me and then i just
messaged you being like hey i want to
draw can you help me i remember the i
think your recent video at that time was
like yuri on ice impressions
god oh
[Applause]
that's my favorite kind of thumbnail
that's like
60 percent so i'm so shocked people like
other youtubers socialize with me back
with them with the weird
but then yeah i remember that uh we i
don't know why we spoke and then i think
well okay
i i don't know what made us like talk
because then i remember i was like oh
i'm thinking about doing this video
where i'd yeah league as well
i found that you played league while we
were doing our first collab or something
because i was like i want to draw some
stuff and i and i wanted you to like
roast me or something but you were too
nice
you weren't you weren't saying mean
things at all
you were you know how things are
yeah i think that's how we became
friends and then you asked me to voice
him on your videos i think yeah and then
you know the ball came from from there
yeah then we played league yeah and then
now we're here
did you like know about like the story
time scene or did you just kind of like
discover it as you did it i discovered
it as i did it so then that's how i
started watching like other people and i
was like well this whole community and
then
and then i initially i wasn't gonna like
get involved in the community because at
the time i was like all night friends ah
that's so juvenile it's like middle
school that's the last time i had an
online friend all right and then now
most of my friends are online
i mean i think cause when you're when
you don't really wanna interact with
circles but you become like i guess
very big in a certain community yeah you
kind of almost expected to talk to other
creators in it almost weirdly you kind
of you know you you always get pressured
by your audience as well yeah yeah
hey collab
yeah you're the only one not talking to
everyone it's kind of like i guess i
should say hi
yeah but it also kind of like weirdly is
be like oh wow like does he think he's
better than the rest of us
sometimes when there's someone in the
community who just doesn't interact with
anyone there's like an air of mystery
there yeah yeah you know what i mean
he's so cool yeah i'm just like damn i
wonder who he talks to man what always
is that and then that person's secretly
wishing everyone had reached out
i wish they reached out to me
so many times oh my god but like your
your rise was like fast i remember that
when i found your videos you were
getting a few hundred thousand which is
a lot but i remember you know you you
can get up to like 10 10 million views
i remember whenever you made like an
anime video it just like would not
disappear from my timeline every time
you were yeah
yeah that was crazy i think that was
yeah i think that's
2018 2019 with was i think like my
fastest growing period and it was insane
yeah it was crazy i remember your growth
was just
nuts yeah
was it like how what kind of growth were
you seeing within that one year because
that was that was that one year when you
started youtube and then you just blew
up immediately yeah oh my god like two
million subs super fast right yeah i
think so in like a year was it like
daunting like two years was it yeah it
was two years but a million a year is
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah it was crazy was
it was it daunting just have like this
massive audience just come to you in
like a year yeah though so the way i
always describe it which always like
it like blows my mind because like when
you look at the numbers it's very easy
to like yeah view it as just odds it's a
number yeah but then you have to
consider like do you ever have that
thought every time you pass a stranger
on this on the street you're like this
person why are you laughing because
you're literally describing that meme in
the party where he's like they don't
know i mean
they could have watched my videos
you you passed a stranger on the street
and
like for a brief moment you
have this understanding that they're an
entire person who has lived an entire
life separate from you
and they have their own set of like
problems and like motivations and like
just all the stuff you don't know about
they that's like a whole ass
[Music]
of people and emily's just like let's uh
let's characterize all two million ones
of my audience like what's your back
story all right one down one like can
you imagine how many arcs they've been
through in their entire life it's like a
million
yeah it's still daunting
yeah yeah yeah yeah like now that you've
said it like that i'm like oh my god i'm
i'm thinking about it and i'm like [ __ ]
that's that's nice i'm scared now that's
that's a lot of people there's a lot to
think about yeah when you put it like
that there's so much pressure you're
putting on yourself though yeah yeah
i don't know because i'm like now i'm
not gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm not now i'm like
overwhelmed
oh no i'm sorry
i can't i can't do this all the time get
out of your head never mind i just
assume my audience is like on the same
level of depth as like a [ __ ] isaki
protagonist or something that just makes
it easier to digest npc number two
but like then they don't think about you
that deeply they're like that ain't that
deep they just like watching
i like this video yeah yeah literally
like i think about how you watch videos
you're not like man i that's a real
person with a you're like well he funny
funny sticky people mean you know what i
mean
i wonder how old he is right now i
wonder i wonder what he's doing i wonder
what led him up to that moment now
there's
oh yeah like when you say like that yeah
it is it is very very [ __ ] daunting
um how the [ __ ] did you get past that
yeah i guess like because because i grew
like gradually i guess so i i got to
like it i was like like increments yeah
like warmed up to it you know i gotta
ask because you blew up really quickly
you know normally when you when you grow
really quickly there's normally like
some kind of uh
sometimes your friends can be weird
about it or sometimes people you kind of
you didn't really speak to come and
suddenly start visiting
how many like new facebook whatever
really like people from my past come and
be like hey what's up i saw you do you
like i haven't gotten many of that at
all really i think
uh i'll try to make this brief because
it was like a
not so good experience i think the worst
uh that's ever happened
was like there was a girl that i was
good friends with in high school
and then in college like we just didn't
talk because we went to some different
schools and we just like didn't talk it
just happens with your friends uh but i
saw her because she cosplayed and so i
saw her at like a local con
this was like i think when i was during
my first year of youtube right
um
but i saw her at a con and i came up to
her and i was like hey like how are you
it's been so long and i remember she
looked at me and she was like i don't
really have the time for this and i was
like she said that yeah
i'm sorry like i don't know you're busy
my bad i'll just uh okay i'll just go
over there i don't care how busy
you are that is not the excuse you go
for that you don't have the time ten
million i don't have different ways to
say that better yeah and not be an
[ __ ] about it like i remember like i
felt really sad the whole day because i
was like yeah i would be too what the
[ __ ] i saw that you like unfollowed me
on like instagram which would
it shouldn't matter but i was like what
did i do i mean combined with that
insult to injury it's like yo what the
[ __ ]
jesus apparently she did have the time
for it because she had the time to like
log into her instagram
unfollow yeah yeah right
fast forward like a year later
but since the growth was like insane
yeah i have like a bigger following now
and i was walking through the convention
with one of my friends and suddenly here
like oh my god is that emily and i was
like huh and i looked over and it's that
same girl and i was like i thought we
weren't i thought you didn't like me
like what's going on but
no i did it because i was so sh yeah you
should i don't have time for this
the perfect story
[Laughter]
and then and then i realized because she
was like oh my little cousin watches you
i didn't know you had a youtube channel
that's so crazy the lion the witch and
the audacity
yeah and i got i got kind of annoyed
because at one point she was like
oh yeah like it's so crazy like how you
like talking your videos like that's not
you i know you and i'm like no you don't
we haven't spoken since high school and
i'm now like 22. you don't know me you
didn't have time for me back then yeah
what makes you think you have time for
me you should be like would you look at
the time
i don't have any for you this is not
like the snoop dogg like whoo
it was really bizarre and like since
then i will sometimes like run into her
at cons
and she'll like and she'll be like oh
hey like how are you and i'm like we're
still doing this like i i don't think
until you like give it like the heart
like i don't have time for your level of
like treatment i think she's just going
to like keep pretending but i don't want
her to be like oh you got a big head now
because like you gotta fall no because
she clearly had a big head to begin with
yeah like back then with what she said
to you
yeah i mean i guess but that's too nice
i don't want to emily's just like so
positive i'm just like yeah
i would take advantage of this that i
think was like the the best example of
like oh someone's treating me
differently yeah they know i have a
following yeah yeah yeah other than that
no what about like online how did you
handle online like just a massive influx
of suddenly like a lot of people online
watching you and interacting with you oh
that was kind of nerve-wracking of
course yeah um
i mean i don't know just but then just
doing it right just didn't you blow it
while you like your videos took off
while you're still working though
so here's the other thing um
so like i think people have this a lot
of people still have this idea that i am
like this uber wholesome
innocent bun
uh who could never curse i mean i don't
know who would they watch your videos
how could why would they think maybe
because they only watch your videos yeah
your videos get like 10 million views
maybe i always get like a millionaire
yeah yeah so at the beginning
my videos were like extremely tame
because when i was still when i was
doing youtube during that first year i
was still working with kids
like an after school program at this
like catholic school right right and i'm
not catholic that's just what i was
playing
yeah if you started doing like
so some kids like found out about my
channel and then
parents know that i have a youtube
channel and so i'm like well i can't i
can't like curse or like say anything
weird on my youtube channel because they
know i work with their kids i don't want
them to mistrust me
so
for a while i think i think that's where
that kind of started
oh emily is
like wholesome bean yeah she would never
think a lute thought in her life
and
uh
so then after i quit that job um then i
felt more comfortable to like oh well
now i can like be sort of more myself
when i make videos right
in every video
yeah
and
one of the things that still bothers me
a little bit about like i don't know
having an online presence i i can't
speak for everyone obviously
but i feel like
i feel like with a lot of like female
creators you're put in one of two boxes
you are either a innocent
virginal
wholesome being who must be protected
yep or you're a [ __ ] gobbling [ __ ]
and there's no in between
you are not a three-dimensional i i want
to like say you you're wrong but i think
it's somewhat accurate yeah it's pretty
yeah yeah
unfortunately yeah and like in the
viewer's eyes
i speak for everyone else
obviously but i sometimes i feel like a
lot of like female creators feel the
pressure to put themselves in one or two
boxes right right so it's like oh i i
have to be say so i'm 25 and i don't
know what an innuendo is right because
if they knew that i knew they wouldn't
like me anymore yeah or it's like oh no
if i don't i don't know talk about dicks
for the 17th time today people will
forget about me
what are you watching
who is this crazy
it got to the point where like i would
draw fan art and if i drew like a little
cleavage people would be like i thought
you were i thought you were wholesome i
thought you were wholesome and i clearly
don't know that that female has a life
of her own you know she's a whole lost
human being you can be wholesome and
draw like a titty it's fine
and like
it doesn't bother me that much
it's like if it's kids i get it
yeah yeah yeah but what like weirded me
out is when it's like grown people who
are like surprised that me a fellow
grown person yeah
knows what a dirty joke is yeah yeah
yeah and because i've noticed i noticed
sydney has also had to deal with i guess
something similar just on like the
opposite end of the spectrum yeah yeah
because she does make content on
covering like the more adult side of
things they just assume that's her only
person
they just assume that's her only
personality i remember like like two
weeks ago or something she was just
hanging out she was back in england like
a week before me or something and she
was just went out to hang out uh with
one of her best friends who happened to
be a guy but like
it's just it's just like he's just like
a normal guy yeah right
and he's not that involved in the anime
community or whatever he's just a guy
and i remember he was just like happy
that he got to see what he's one of his
best friends and he posted it on twitter
and i remember just like seeing like the
comment chain of this was just like
it was it was just lntr
yeah yeah and i remember i remember
talking to eugene afterwards he was just
like
what is this i like he he was so out of
his perception of like how people act in
his world he was just like what is going
on right now i just posted the picture
just hanging out with sydney right
and it was yeah it was it was it was so
it was it was so surreal as well because
uh because you know they were they were
just having like a normal hangout you
know and yeah that was pretty much it
um and uh it wasn't like sydney it
wasn't even placed on sydney's account
he was like person on his personal
account as well
uh his personal account so it was like
all the replies going on his account so
you just said yeah yeah it was just
really weird to see i think
[Music]
you're virgin or goblin horror there's
no in between because i think i think
it's like i think a lot of people forget
that
you know it's not funny
but like not everyone around your life
is you know to do with let's say your
personality or your work you know just
because you talk about x doesn't mean
like everyone you associate with and
talk to and relates with is you know
understands the same feeling in the same
circle yeah of course of course um and
it's sometimes easy to forget that
online basically creators have uh
creators have backstories and characters
my friend solei i have her in like a
bunch of my videos but she
outside of that she just does not have a
life on youtube she has like her own
life and she at one point had to make
like a second twitter account right
because she couldn't post anything
without people being like were you with
emily what was emily doing and she was
like i don't know
my life doesn't revolve around her i
remember she got she got super fed up
because one valentine's day she posted a
picture of like burritos she got with
her boyfriend right and they say his
and hers on that yeah she goes oh look
what they wrote on our burritos and we
went to get them right and someone was
like oh did you get burritos with with
emily she's like they say his and hers
like uh and it's valentine's day
obviously it was my boyfriend what are
you talking about oh my gosh
people be wild
yeah so like have you had to like
struggle with
like people you seeing seeing you that
way or have you like tried to like break
the image at all
um
no i it just like it's a little annoying
when it happens but i mean i get it i
think it's because it's like i have a
drawn persona and i feel like people
associate like ooh drawings yeah
childlike yeah and i also really like
cutesy things so it doesn't surprise me
that people
like perceive me that way yes i think
it's also that because because of the
community you're in where a lot of like
the story time youtubers are seen as
like the family-friendly kind of like
personality yeah and like kind of
branding in general yeah i think uh i
think that plays a part into it as well
and
the reason why i don't curse very much
in my videos is uh
because
there have been too many horror stories
i've heard of people like in the
storytime community slaving away over
like a video yeah but they say like one
curse word yeah in like the first i
guess the most
immediately gets you monetized yeah yeah
like a month's worth of work which i
totally get right you put like a few
months work into this video and you say
[ __ ] once and you're like okay income
gone it's so strange i have to say like
some really abhorrent stuff to get
demonetised i can say like [ __ ] as many
times as i want it doesn't get to
monetize i mean i it's never happened
maybe it shows like it's like are you
british his past
yeah dada said this on the last episode
as well
he doesn't curse because of that as well
yeah yeah which is understandable but it
makes you want to curse more right i'd
want to curse more
channels yeah
they're like
first time like you drew like you came
on my challenge and you were like
swearing i remember like a bunch of
comments you were like whoa emily's
really crude in this video and it's like
it's they're not they don't say i'm
crude that's how i normally have and
you're acting like a normal conversation
yeah i don't even think i was cursing
accessories you weren't you were you
said [ __ ] once or twice and then i was
like
we we we get the opposite right like if
we're like doing like a sponsored
content on someone else's channel or
whatever or like you know it's a channel
we've done like interviews or something
and our audience finds it yeah um
we always get comments being like i've
never seen the boys so well spoken in my
life
it's like they're so professional yeah i
shouldn't say [ __ ] what i sound so much
more well-spoken when i don't
swear but it's so boring it's so natural
for you though i feel like
swearing is the spice of like language
you know it's like it's like how much
spice do you want inside yeah keep
putting that i just like okay don't stop
okay stop stop stop kind of stop
it's too spicy i don't know
it's such a
i love swearing in what it does in the
english language it's so powerful and
it's yeah it conveys emotions really
well absolutely and i think that's one
thing i really love about english is
that you can get like a such a precise
emotion with the right combination of
swearing
i definitely feel that that's one aspect
japanese doesn't have as strong in
english
because they have custom for everything
because everything is kuso it's like
come on
where's your bell end where's your knob
head we have like
you know what i mean like we've got like
500 different ways of saying like the
exact same thing all of them are like
slight different shades of insult yeah
why do you think i love swearing in
english because
japanese yeah right right i'm like i
feel i feel so empty when there's no
[ __ ] in japanese i just feel like i'm
just saying in english the sheer level
of creativity and insults in english is
so deep yeah it just makes me love it
just just think about how malleable the
word [ __ ] is it's just like it blows my
mind sometimes yeah [ __ ] well every
language [ __ ] can be every emotion every
scenario all right yeah [ __ ] exactly
yeah yeah you always say [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'll be like oh we're having noodles
like [ __ ] no way
[ __ ]
there's no way this video is not getting
demonetized now yeah
wait is it the first 15 minutes
yeah i think we're good sorry oh no no
it's okay when i when i do curse i just
like cover it with a sensor yeah yeah i
i don't acknowledge the fact that there
are a lot of like younger people
watching me and i don't want to like
make that a habit for them yeah what
sensor do you use do you use like the
quack sensor that like i used the senko
oh okay yeah
can you give me a taste
how'd it go
which one was it i think i think i used
the windows error noise oh you do
not look it's like this anime girl like
[Music]
i [ __ ] hate oh one
people love it so i keep using it now
the duck one is more annoying for me
yeah i don't like the dark one either
how does that work
that's how you know you're on a gaming
let's play champion yeah yeah right
yeah
normally i don't just yeah i guess
that's why a lot of my videos get do you
want to monetize i don't normally censor
myself yeah it's that in the anime
titties
this is why we have patrons yeah yeah
yeah
exactly yeah what were you talking about
before i completely forgot
about uh
online audience yeah yeah yeah
yeah like online friends and stuff like
did you ever get like because like when
i
you know started to get a little more
you know attention online and you know
because i never told any of my friends
like i didn't tell any of my friends in
college or high school or anything oh
yeah i didn't even tell any of my like
only my close friends yeah everyone i
didn't even tell my close friends like
there was just like a thing to myself
and then you had a montana moment yeah
i didn't have the best of both worlds
so like you know so i i noticed it when
i randomly got like
one day i went on to like facebook
messenger and i got like 10 messages
from like high school friends i haven't
spoken to since i graduated they were
like yeah i found you on youtube when
did you start that we should hang out or
something and i was just like
no
i don't think so
like you didn't have that at all
maybe like a few that were like oh let's
meet up or did you get someone recently
on league who's like messaging oh
there's someone i played league of
legends with he was cool about it though
there was someone i played league of
legends with back in high school like i
never even met them in person oh okay
but okay like it was like an online
friend yeah right but i hadn't spoken to
them in years yeah you got them from the
friends list you just left them on the
friends yesterday yeah yeah they were
like last online five years ago or
whatever
actually my first night in japan they
had like messaged me yeah all right they
were like hey can i ask you like a
really bizarre question and i'm like
what's up and he's like
funny thing is he didn't even
find out from like my youtube he found
out from like a youtuber clip yeah right
so he was like he's like a
tuber now
and i was like
why
and he's like oh i found like a
i found a clip because my league name
uh is is emery um yeah and so he he sort
of was like well marichu emery that kind
of sounds similar yeah both of their
names are emily right is this you and i
was like miss you
and i was like yeah
and he's like oh okay i just want to
confirm that's super cool like good job
yeah
he was super cool about it yeah that's
good though it was really nice and i was
like oh yeah like hope and then we
caught up and i was like how have you
been doing
yeah it's better than that no yeah it's
really weird for me because like when
when i when i did youtube as my job i
didn't really get so many messages from
people in my past just randomly
messaging me it was when
i moved to japan and because it wasn't
even about youtube i would just get
random messages to be like oh i heard
you like living in japan now i've always
wanted to visit
but they would find out because i
because of trash taste right but they
wouldn't be interested in like my work
or anything that'd be like so they're
like finally a tour guide yeah yeah
so it's a free tour right now yes i like
it so if i come over first time you can
show me around right first time
literally my entire life
yeah you know my pain
i think it's been like a blessing and a
curse that the country's been closed
yeah
you're just going to get like a massive
rush of people to be like saw him in
japan
show me around i was until i joined
so how was the process
coming here like how was the getting the
visa and all that we asked diet is the
same thing too it wasn't that terrible i
think you got you guys are like the
guinea pigs
yeah yeah
yeah that would definitely be pretty
sorry but the the only thing that like
really made the process difficult was
you know covet stuff yeah obviously
obviously um
my my embassy experience was a little
more stressful than dides's i'd say
so he might he probably explained it but
for him the way he got his visa was
didn't even make an appointment went to
boston rolled up hey uh i've got this
from this
and they're like all right come back in
a week he's like cool bye yeah
my closest embassy was l.a
okay i'm betting they were a lot busier
oh yeah
so i called to be like can i make an
appointment and the lady was like okay
here's what you got to do so tonight at
around 11 59 p.m there's gonna a few
slots are going to open up but people
want those thoughts you gotta like
hunger games that [ __ ] oh my god
well really okay
um
and ended up getting one slot
such a police set to like set an alarm
to be like all all right i'm gonna phone
now refreshing now yeah i was refreshing
it oh you're watching oh my god um i got
it and then
two days later got an email that was
like due to the high number of visa
applications we are no longer taking
in-person appointments uh-huh so you
gotta mail your stuff in by the way you
need to sign this waiver saying that if
we lose your [ __ ] it's not our fault and
i was like
i was so stressed
um it worked out though yeah i got my
visa yeah and then
um
i think getting to the the whole i think
the most difficult like physically
mentally difficult part for me was when
i finally landed and i had to go through
this three-hour queue yeah yeah
and show my passport like 17 times yeah
different people yeah yeah i had to show
my dog and like the worst part was if
i'm wearing a mask you can't tell that
i'm
a different type of asian yeah yeah yeah
so at everything can you tell with the
mask off that you're like korean
no i don't think even even though i was
gonna say can you distinguish between
japanese and korean like just by looking
um
yeah my i went i went to see an ear
doctor a few days ago and he knew
immediately i was korean it was
really cool yeah it looks at the shape
of urine you're like you're korean
i didn't even look at your face it's
like that's a korean right there
it's like can you tell the difference
between a british person and a french
person if they don't open that maybe
that's because i'm white i feel like
sometimes i can yeah yeah it's it's like
every time but like
you can kind of tell subtle
subtle or i can tell like when a white
person doesn't speak english
i can't tell that yeah i can't tell them
i can't tell them just look it's coming
on look they're going
to look they haven't watched like all
eight seasons of 24. you know what i
mean i can just like tell i've gotten
pretty good at like kind of
distinguishing between chinese and
japanese but sometimes korean and
japanese it's like you really don't know
until they open their mouth yeah for me
it's like a lot of the time there's a
difference in like makeup or style
[Music]
which is like the big difference like
it's like if they did the same makeup
style on fashion style there's like no
i'm like i'm like is this asian girl
dressed like everyone around her
probably japanese yeah yeah skirt length
is a big towel yeah yeah yeah yeah i
think that's the biggest tell to figure
out this thing
like yeah that makes you sound like i
look like it's like can i see your knees
i have to save
i have never felt more like
skanky
than
that's why i said that okay i i'm not
looking at people's skirts
and i'm like it's short skirt weather
baby let's go i'm wearing a shirt i'm
wearing like a a skirt let's go i walk
out everyone's covered head to toe yeah
yeah japanese women normally wear skirts
like literally down to like here yeah
like it is like ankle covered like we're
in the 1700s
and i'm like oh my god i hope i don't
look like
tacky and classless yeah but also it's
hot why
well i don't understand how like
japanese businessmen no matter how hot
it is we'll wear a suit fully yeah but
that's why with a vest underneath that's
why so many people here die of heat
strokes
because they're literally just like no i
must not show any skin whatsoever i will
die for my course but then on the
opposite side of things sometimes it
gets like dead in the winter and the
girls are still wearing like even
shorter skirts
like how does that make sense right
they're still wearing the skirts and
everyone is just like i'm like dude you
have a like a bath towel on how are you
like people either assume right away i'm
a foreigner or they think i'm just like
a very bold
yeah japanese someone like you're making
a statement
is that a careful whoa
have you had a lot of awkward encounters
or people think you speak japanese
because you oh my god that was my entire
three-hour airport experience i would go
to the next document
and i'm like what kind of night here are
my documents they're like oh [ __ ] oh
okay uh do this and i'm like okay cool
next night
what kind of knife hear myself did you
see do you see like because this
happened to me a few a few times and
every time they get it wrong that i see
like the disappointment in their eyes it
makes me feel so bad i know
yeah you know i've been learning you've
been doing really well really yeah i
mean you you like go out there like i
was like i just say this and then you
immediately you're like i'm going to say
it i'm going to do it i'm so ordering
and i was like wow okay that's the best
way to learn it man yeah
because i mean normally like you know
it's understandably it's quite
intimidating having to say a bunch of
things that you don't really fully
understand why you're saying them but
you'd hope to get a certain amount
because then the moment they say
something off script you're just yeah
yeah yeah yeah what do i say this was
part of my training
oh my god
that's good though yeah that's good i
noticed every time i hang out with
connor like i think we have like
different gaps in our knowledge of
japanese so sometimes someone will say
something and i'm just like i kind of
miss that and kind of like immediately
get that and sometimes sometimes someone
will say something connor's just like uh
donato answer i know how to answer and
it's just between me and connor i think
we have like
a good joke
he's like he'll finish my standards for
me
but like yeah how have you started
taking lessons
yeah so i i've done one lesson so far i
do them every week yeah except the past
two weeks i couldn't because my teacher
uh she was busy and then it was golden
week yeah so my next lesson isn't until
a few days but i know how to like
introduce myself yeah i just i was like
just just take my teacher just get her
yeah
very very enthusiastic she's not like
the youtuber teacher because she's
basically she's literally teaching all
the youtubers english sydney emily
building an empire
it's really fun i think one of the most
fun parts is like looking at the symbols
in like hiragana and katakana and trying
to think of ways to remember them oh
right remembering the shapes
yeah yeah one of my favorites is oh god
i know you told me some of them i was
like i was like you're stretching it
dude the hiragana for
wah
most people say it looks like a wasp but
for me it looks like wario's fat dunphy
[Laughter]
so she's like she's like ah forever wow
for warriors fat zombies
the strength of mnemonics is like the
stronger or the more
image yeah the easier it is to remember
and like now that you said that i would
never gonna unscene
even though that's a stretch by the way
i want to say it's not little eyewear i
could see that more than the wasp yeah
the wasp
i don't know if that was true the one
for a like the yeah yeah katakana is
just i like the letter i yeah oh like a
stretched out eye yeah all right so so
like this thing was like this this thing
i i don't know if it was the same one we
used it was like it's an engineering eye
beam so think of engineering for
i feel like we're really twisting like
what we can do here i'm like e for
engineering yeah i i beam that's
actually how i remember it that's how i
i remember excited i'm an engineer yeah
me too but i'm like i'm like i feel like
this is not a good way to do it thus i'm
remembering because i remember that
there was the one dumb one yeah
but the point is you remember right
that's all that matters literally the
fact you brought it up in conversation
because you remember it yeah
it worked but i'm i'm annoyed that it
works because it's dumb like warrior is
fat dumpy oh also the character for roe
yeah looks like a roblox head
no it doesn't
i had this exact same moment i think
everybody learns japanese has this
moment where emily saw
like so you know right yeah there's a
kanji for like gucci yeah like mouth
she's like kind of the same as it all
yeah emily was like i know how to read
this one it's the draw and i'm like
emily it's not wrong
and you're like
but what
but it's wrong
i'm like you're gonna hate this emily
but also care is also a kanji as well
that comes up a lot well you weren't you
were talking about air like the
engineering air right yeah that's also
kanji yeah because like uh like some of
the place names they'll often have the
old ones and it's really annoying yeah
because it's not even remotely similar
yeah
[ __ ] kanji dude also sometimes i oh you
know what really threw me off when i was
trying to learn katakana
a lot of some katakana symbols
look really similar to characters in
korean oh no i've already been
conditioned
really which ones because my head is so
different paul looks like a
one
uh
this one
is going to love editing this one
oh no no no it looks like uh oh my god i
don't know
it looks like yeah yeah what
oh coffee's here our coffee's here
what
looks like i i was wondering like why
you ran off and of course it was because
the coffee came i didn't even realize
yeah i thought connor just like really
desperately needed the toilet because
they're like conversations what the [ __ ]
no he just
we're mid podcasts
this is going to be in the episode he's
just not even here i'm being caffeinated
right now i want to hear it
yeah but yeah like wall like yeah yeah
yeah that's like the korean character
for the
yeah they're remotely similar so i've
had to like extra train my brain same
for the character for uh
yeah yeah it looks like the good sound
so like every time i see it i'm like
good and i'm like no no no it's full so
i have to like really stretch my brain
when i see those characters when i see
foot i have to imagine a comic panel of
like a cute character laughing going
all
it looks like a man running right
you see this right what
pooh looks like a man running dumb
connor
until connor said that i was like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about and then
i saw it and my mind was blown because i
never learned he's not gonna like that
doesn't like men
you just know the language
yeah i just noticed the symbol
and i thought about it i was like
[Music]
oh my god it does it literally looks
like the olympics for like the the
running like what they would use like
because 100 meter dash
i didn't see that until you pointed that
out as well i literally can't unsee it
like i every time i look at it it's like
first it's the man running second it's
poo
no but like it's funny you say that
because like i remember like back in uh
college i spent like a week to challenge
myself to see if i could learn hangul
because like it's easy apparently it's
one of the easiest writing systems like
in the world right because it's only
like 20 yeah something letters right so
yeah but like i used i used the opposite
where like i saw ger and i was like oh
that's just foo
is it that similar it's literally the
same oh it's the same but it's but in in
hungary
i wonder how it is like learning
mandarin from like learning mandarin
kanji man oh dude like i remember like
in in high school in uni when we had
like our japanese like curricula like
place was right next to where mine was
yeah so like there was like all my
friends who were studying japanese and
uni yeah would come out being like [ __ ]
man we're on kanji right now and all the
[ __ ] chinese students just like belly
laughing being like
elementary [ __ ]
i like this years ago
it's like i [ __ ] hate them all
meanwhile we're just like what are these
like hieroglyphs
yeah
this is where we're at now joe this is
this
you can barely laugh now i can barely
laugh now
like elementary my my other favorite one
that i actually taught daidus was the
katakana for for ka
looks like the side profile of samurai
jack and he uses a katana so every time
he sees it he's like he's like what's
this oh samurai jack car
these are getting longer and longer like
why is for uh when you go to the store
and you go wow there's no dishes left
it sounds like a one piece yeah yeah
yeah
it's like so uh so it sounds like having
a lot of fun learning japanese yeah yeah
yeah that's important that's good though
yeah i just learned from like i guess
kind of class but also
having really awkward conversations
where i get things wrong a lot oh well
that's the best way to learn it is i
feel like getting drunk and talking to
japanese people is like the best way
yeah
yeah
yeah because if there's one thing
japanese people love to do is teach
japanese to foreigners yeah like they
love it like if you're in like a bar
setting and you say something a little
bit is wrong then they'll be like uh no
no no it's this is how you say it and
like they want to see you improve right
yeah whereas like i feel you don't
really get that in a lot of like
english-speaking countries i feel mm-hmm
i don't [ __ ] teach english to someone
yeah right no yeah yeah
people like english people get annoyed
when someone goes exactly like they'll
be like so why is the why is there kay
in knight
it looks [ __ ] badass do you think a
knight would look good without a k come
on that's the reason why it's the cool
one it has the edge yeah man that's like
the k is a cool letter
yeah but right it's like i feel that's
just like so interesting how there's
just like that dichotomy right yeah well
i think it's just like because it's the
same with tai as well where if we see
someone trying to actively learn the
language
uh that we speak it's just like we're
proud of that now we're proud that
that's like oh you're taking the time
for us yeah we're proud
with wash actually people if people are
interested i'll tell them yeah
if you're interested in like uh let's
get good
come watch a marvel movie
yeah well i'm glad you're having fun
because like
mnemonics like some of the funnest parts
of just like creating a story like
whenever like you remember a word
because like i still use it whenever i
like try to remember like a new japanese
word or something
um like because you can use it to
remember
um the katakana and the kanji as well
but you can also create stories or like
different things when you're just
remembering words
like for like for example like cheap is
like yasui right and i always remember
like it's so i whenever how i learned
that is i just remember just like i
imagine sydney like picking up like a
really cheap person going yeah
and now i'm just i'm never gonna forget
like that's cheap as yasui because i
just remember yes
no no [ __ ] wonder scientists have no
idea how the [ __ ] brain is yeah
what the [ __ ] is going on
well now i'm gonna remember that that's
so good wait what's expensive
that guy yeah
so are you thinking
have you had any fun or awkward stories
so far i remember you mentioned um
he didn't say this but i remember
hearing the story where
the delivery guys came oh my god oh so
bringing back to the hole like when
people first look at me they expect me
they just assume that i know how to
speak japanese yeah so uh when we were
getting our fridge delivered we didn't
have like
like an interpreter with us at that yeah
yeah we're just getting our fridge
delivered and installed same with our
washing machine
i was in another room during this time
but the fridge guy was trying to
communicate with didis yeah but
obviously like i just can't understand
what he's saying yeah so the delivery
guy was like
ah
honestly
[Laughter]
i feel so bad we have to communicate via
like google translate oh but it's like
at that moment i could feel the
disappointment i i can like you say that
story and i'm like i can feel like his
soul leaving his body just be like [ __ ]
i thought you were my crutch
and you let me down
this kid's just practicing all right
that's good
i had the exact same experience but the
opposite when we went to when aki and i
went to disneyland and because aki looks
way more asian than me yeah people
assume immediately assume she can speak
japanese and i can't so
when there was like a staff member or
there was no there was a japanese woman
who like stopped us to like ask for
directions or something of course she
went to akira
and you know started speaking in
japanese and this is like back when you
know she had just moved and didn't know
that as well
she wasn't as conversational
and i'm like [ __ ] i just spoke to you
i can respond she cannot
why are you looking at her i've
experienced that too yeah i was with
david yeah and david uh speaks really
good
and we would go to like a restaurant and
the person at the front would like talk
to me yeah and then david would like
respond yeah yeah and then the guy's
like oh okay
and i'm like i don't know what you're
saying
i i don't know if you'll experience this
i don't know if it's just because like
i'm white but
sometimes i have this weird moment where
i speak broken japanese and they speak
broken english to me and it's like a
battle of who's gonna who's gonna fold
first
um i i'm gonna i'm gonna keep doing this
i'm i'm really trying to get my hours in
here and he's like no no i'm gonna help
you i'm doing it i'm helping you out at
the moment there is fun back in brooklyn
english you just hear like the dark
souls like that
i'm not we're not full i feel like
process i'm like am i going to speak
back in english no i'm going to try i
can respond to this in japanese this is
fine
there's this difficulty level i can
handle yeah
because like
what i noticed with japanese people is
that the first language you speak to
them in yeah like no matter what like
the first language you speak to them
they will always try to respond to you
in that language and like if you speak
english to them and then later on you
start you know trying to speak japanese
they would try to respond back to you in
english english yeah but i've also had
it where i've like even though i've
spoken like the most broken japanese
right i remember like
uh back when i was like
uh back when we had to get like cover
tests and we had to like phone up a
clinic together to get some code uh to
get
get a pcr test um there was this clinic
that
apparently you know they they spoke
english right but i know what that means
right i know what that means
this is like the only time in japan
where they're like actually just full on
[ __ ] live yeah yeah yeah they just
they literally click facebook yeah so i
phoned up the clinic and of course
they're speaking in japanese so i'm like
okay it's one of those i'm gonna have to
like practice my japanese so i start i
start speaking the most broken japanese
trying to book my appointment and
everything's going fine and then they
asked like a they asked like they asked
a question off the script
just like they asked a complicated
question that is like way above my level
and i'm just like
like he starts speaking in perfect
english i'm like [ __ ]
[ __ ] like
like this is the one time you can start
speaking english and then he explains it
to me in perfect english right i'm like
oh great great i'm like okay that's fine
and then he goes back to speaking
japanese again
even though like he's like i'm done now
even though he can clearly hear that i'm
like really struggling with my japanese
what if that's the only line in english
that he can actually speak
so continue your free trial of english
like your 30-day trial has exploded
please pie winrar
it's weird because like every single
clinic i've been to that advertises like
english yeah it's always been like a the
doctor speaks maybe like hello yeah and
like maybe maybe can kind of explain
like
he kind of understands it's it's really
bad i mean i just went to one recently
right and hear the same thing and the
only time i've ever had have ever had a
doctor who spoke like perfect english
was one where they didn't advertise it
as being english right and the doctor
just was like oh yeah by the way i lived
in america for six years and and studied
medicine and i was like
why didn't you advertise that you could
speak english like i would die
yeah like every single other one says
they speak english and they don't speak
english and like one of them was is like
attached to a pharmacy right
so the doctor said that he spoke english
spoke like no word of english he didn't
so i was trying to explain i had a sore
throat and he was like
he didn't uh know the word for throat so
i said it in japanese oh okay i get it i
was like you don't have the word for
throat
you're a doctor bro it's covered time
just like one of the only things you
should know yeah yeah like what
sorry so i get my prescription i go over
of course the guy who's giving me the
subscription she starts speaking to me
in perfect english
and i'm like
you should swap with this guy you should
be the doctor you should swap because i
mean you basically same thing right i
think i i just take whenever you go onto
a clinic website or whatever and it says
oh it can speak english
i just take that now as not the doctor
can speak english i just take that as
the doctor isn't afraid of foreigners
yeah yeah yeah yeah and it's like and if
it doesn't say it then the doctor is
like oh [ __ ] i just walked in
no we're busy sorry it sucks because i
feel like i to get to the level of
proficiency in japanese to feel
comfortable talking about really like
what could be sensitive information yeah
like it could be life or death
information it's like okay
even if i felt like super confident i
would still want someone who's native to
come be like can you can you help
explain it or i want english right
because you don't [ __ ]
there's a few things where like i i'm
fine trying to stumble through but if
there's one thing i'm not i'm like
health i'm just like i want to make sure
i'm communicating exactly what i need to
do okay uh visa documents i like i'm i
need to [ __ ] know that i can get back
into the country all right to be fair
like you know i've been to some clinics
where they've said a japanese word and
i'm just like what yeah right yeah and
then i look it up in english and it's
like oh okay
yeah yeah but like you know i don't know
how to communicate that to the doctor
right you must be like like ten times
more difficult i can't take most
medicine like most over-the-counter
medicine because most of it like is uh
i just for some reason like you like
pepto-bismol
ibuprofen all of that stuff i can't take
right uh it's like things your blood oh
um so i can't take any of that so like
when i'm talking to the doctor it's like
i i have this condition i'm like it's
not a big deal like everything's chill
super chill just please don't give me
medicine i can't take i'm begging you
yeah so like i learned the japanese word
for your condition
what is it when you got oh [ __ ]
because
the only time i use it is when i had to
go get medicine for this guys
the doctor in the pharmacy that like oh
my friend has this condition but i
didn't know what it was in japanese i i
think i know the kanji for it because
i've had to brokenly write it out a few
times on forms
and it's like like a one-year-old wrote
it yeah like i'm pretty sure if you
wrote country like that in china you
wouldn't be allowed to progress
it's like
or something like that something along
those lines you see how close
i don't actually remember
because that means blood okay okay okay
um
okay so i should know this because i
have it i probably should learn it
yes i've got kittens i know i know the
kanji because the first one is blood and
then it's like like tomodachi kind of
looking ass it looks like
oh yeah
you know what language moment i
find so inspiring
a few years ago during the trip that i
was on to osaka with my mom and my dad
we actually got lost at one point yeah
and we couldn't figure out how to get to
the station we're trying to get to and
nobody that we were stopping
could understand us and we couldn't
understand them
and so we were like freaking out and
finally we find this police officer guy
who like walks up to us
and uh he starts like speaking to us in
japanese yeah and my dad's like oh no i
don't understand i like i don't speak
japanese yeah and this guy in perfect
english just goes he's like this old
dude in perfect english he goes what
language would you like me to speak
[Music]
and he starts rattling off in korean
what about us bro he's like one of those
like og language youtubers that like i
will give you a hundred dollars if you
speak a language i don't know yeah
the fact that you can you can be
proficient in so many just to be like
give me one i'll put it out
he was literally just like name a
country that's so that's
such a [ __ ] flex yeah that's what i'm
saying if i if i had to choose a
superpower my superpower would be i wish
i could speak in every language
i would be being able to immediately
guess the country on geogaster by like
the landscape people are like oh this
sound only exists in like the northern
uh uh kenya actually uh and i'm like how
the [ __ ] do you know that off like a 10p
google pixel image what
you know you know i had i had a moment
like that as well um i did actually you
know this strip club video that just
came out recently i think by the time
this thing came out old news but i i did
a video about the strip club
and i i i did this thing and like none
of them spoke english and a lot of and i
was filming with caho but i was
backstage with these dudes a lot of the
time yeah and i just communicate with
them in like really broken japanese and
sakura wasn't there to help me and so
yeah seems going well i mean you know we
were there for like a whole like four or
five hours filming and like
so there's like six dancers and like in
the last 30 minutes one of the dancers
and like the most american ass accent
was like oh yeah i'm having fun man
and i was like i've been speaking you in
the shittiest japanese i told him like
why didn't you [ __ ] tell me you could
speak english he was like i don't know i
was having a good time
[Applause]
because i didn't know what was happening
yeah because they only told me like two
dances
you choreography to go along with you
know what i mean like i'm i'm dying out
here
so he's really nice and uh he does
really amazing artwork on his instagram
you know really nice guys such good
english then he lived in like ohio for a
long time this guy was like like like
his body looked like a like a greek like
form it was amazing he was just like
yeah i just loved america the gyms were
awesome yeah and i was like see like i
i used to love doing that but the
opposite yeah when i was like with
around with my friends and like you know
of course i'd be the [ __ ] token
tourist guide of japan right yeah so i'd
be like taking my friends and then just
some days i'm just like you know what
i'm i'm gonna be one of you
and just not speak a word of japanese
wherever i go so like i remember
i was taking one of my australian
friends and he was like oh i'll
introduce you to my japanese friend and
i'm like you have another japanese
friend why are you getting me to [ __ ]
talk
so anyway i met this girl
and you know she starts speaking in
japanese and i'm just like i'm going to
see how far i can take this
and i just and i was just like hey
what's up and just start speaking to her
in english and she's and she can't speak
english or not very well right so she's
like talking to me in broken english the
entire day i don't speak a word of
japanese to her until the very end
oh my god you're cruel
that poor girl must have been like [ __ ]
i don't know what to talk to i was just
like mid-conversation and i'm just like
yeah so that was really good and then
japanese i'm like so anyway uh i can
speak japanese
and the look on her face like you would
have thought she saw like the face of
god she's just like
what the [ __ ]
this is like the [ __ ] video where
like a celebrity will wear like a
disguise and go out into the public and
be like yo i was cristiano ronaldo this
entire time or something like that you
know no one asked yeah
i don't troll often but that was the one
time i trolled and it was the best
feeling in my life so i can definitely
see my people troll now do you ever hear
people like talking [ __ ] in japanese all
the time of course uh like uh when i was
doing that quite a lot yeah when i was
when i was little i remember when i was
little like maybe like ten nine years
old and i was in a supermarket
yeah yeah yeah yeah i think i haven't
have i told this one yeah
but basically i was like picking snacks
with my sister and these like [ __ ]
you know little [ __ ] i remember this
yeah just like being like look at those
phones
and then my sister and i heard that and
we just looked at each other like let's
get them
and then we just start speaking in
perfect japanese and the kids are just
like oh [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] out of here
this is like balled out i'm like yeah
that's right
get out of here get out of here get out
of here i don't know why this has
happened but i've walked into bars like
very small bars that sit like four or
five people numerous times and i'll
literally like sit down and someone like
like that close to me were like oh
gaijin this yeah like gaijin and i'll be
like what
what i know what that is like i'm like
why would you say that like who says
that yeah you were like does this people
do this in america like oh foreigner
[Laughter]
like what
it's like it's like you live in tokyo
have you never seen
it it the same in korea whenever you go
to korea where
whenever there is like a lot of a big
group of foreigners that come in a bar
or an establishment people notice them
because it's the same in thailand
where we have like a word for foreigners
as well uh what's the word
yeah do you just say it huh then like do
thai people just like say it if there's
like a foreigner next to them i guess so
i mean that's that's how we refer to
foreigners there it's just like oh
you know it's right it's it's like like
even like if you're a foreigner living
in thailand you know the word for lang
because because you refer to yourself
you refer you are the falang of your
thai group probably you know that's that
that's that's how you that's how
you refer to them from like the
the few times i've been to korea and
from what i've seen
it didn't really it doesn't really seem
to be that much of a reaction right
sometimes they can tell when i'm
checking out they can before i even say
anything they can tell that i'm not from
there yeah yeah and they'll just like
it's not like uh like oh my god they're
just like oh okay you want a receipt
i guess to be fair like english is a lot
more commonly spoken in korea than it is
in like a lot of asian countries right
oh it is i think so i have no idea yeah
like i'm pretty sure like i remember i
saw this like youtube video ages ago
where this like
you know clearly foreign looking like
child actor who is perfectly flawed in
korean what they did like it was like a
social experiment videos you know when
that when that was a thing and it was
like if the kid the foreign looking kid
only spoke in english then will korean
people like stop to help out and there
was like a surprising amount of people
maybe in like the big cities who spoke
english i think yeah i think people in
korea aren't really that surprised
especially if it's in like tour yeah
like because i've noticed that like when
i walk with my mom and i'm speaking in
english nobody gives a [ __ ] they're just
like oh okay they're not like oh gosh
yeah
i've noticed that like in japan i just
like say something and i remember i was
on the phone and i was talking to didis
yeah uh because he had gotten to the
studio before me and i was telling him
like i'm on my way yeah yeah everyone
that walked by the double take right
it's because it's because it's because
you're an asian woman though so they
just expect
for you to be speaking in japanese right
now maybe because if you were white then
they wouldn't [ __ ] bat an eye yeah
but because you look just like trading
stocks or something if you're white on
the phone
sell my entire stock yeah but because
because you look asian right they're
just like oh wait how why is she not
speaking in japanese that's [ __ ]
weird let's do a double take that's
probably what it is yeah because he gets
the exact same thing yeah
yeah i remember we went on the trip
recently and like whenever because we
went to some towns and cities that
weren't like so big or well known for
tourists like every time we'd uh every
time we'd walk in we'd have to be like
yo who's the most japanese person out of
our group
joey i guess you're the most japanese
person you're gonna hit them with them
yeah joey always got so annoyed you're
like jerry can you go in first
i was like
we have two other people who can speak
japanese
but i'm just like joey you're the most
they can speak japanese but you're the
most japanese looking person you gotta
go in because right after you secure the
table then
the clown the clown car
foreign all the foreigners walk in right
they're just gonna be like whoa
one semi-japanese looking dude who was
like oh yeah five people please they're
gonna expect four other japanese guys
meanwhile
secured the foreign and we walked in and
it was like that scene in a cowboy movie
where you walk into the barn the entire
bar just shuts up and looks at you that
was what it was like when we just walked
in i i i could see the look on the guy's
face because
he because there's this crucial moment
if if all of you are foreign foreigner
and they walk in where they're like
they're like contemplating whether it's
worth it yeah like to like be like ah
and yeah he we came in and you could
look that he was like oh
yeah he has that phase of like i've made
a terrible way
literally like it was it was clearly
like a local like uh yakitori place
right yeah yeah yeah and then like
one of the only eighties
so there was just enough room on this
one table for all of us and there's like
maybe like three groups of two and they
literally all just stopped eating and
turned around yeah yeah i just like
looked at us
there's one person that can speak it
shouldn't that be like okay good there's
at least one person that it's not about
speaking it's about like
being playing the part yeah you gotta
like
fit what they expect
yeah because japanese people uh
don't like something outside of their
comfort zone yeah it's not it sounds
like discrimination and like and racism
and stuff it's not it's not that it's
that they're so worried that they're not
going to be able to like help you yeah
like serve you that like if you just go
in with someone who kind of puts them at
ease yeah sounds so so stupid but it
makes the whole process just way easier
yeah and it's not that like i'm not like
i don't want to go in
because i'm like oh no i'm scared it's
like no i just i want to make sure we
can all eat and it's like it's a pain in
the ass yeah just go in get it done
we'll be chill yeah you know if there's
two of us i don't give a [ __ ] two people
they don't care yeah but like when
there's a lot of you and a lot of
foreigners they think okay maybe they're
gonna be loud maybe they're not all not
gonna understand they're gonna be rowdy
yeah yeah yeah
you guys remember the hokkaido yakitori
place where everyone was like oh yeah
dude we were in like the middle of
nowhere in hokkaido yeah and then like
like this whole bar was clearly like a
local bar because there was only like
three bars in this whole yeah like
100 kilometer radius yeah and we walked
in and literally the entire time people
were just like eating their food like
like that's out of the order
[Music]
they phoned the entire village to be
like yo you'll never get it just came
out to come check this out
but then the moment i started talking to
the potential in japanese they're like
oh yeah
he was super chill like the guy
the guy running the ball was like
whatever man but like it's the customers
who walked in like whoa yeah
this is a place where foreigners would
never go to be fair like there's there's
no reason you would ever be there as a
foreigner most japanese people wouldn't
have ever seen for some of those people
i bet
yeah we're like probably
in that part of town at least it's a
place most japanese people probably
wouldn't go as well because it was weird
it was it was very very icy it was
literally like
three four hours drive from like
like a town like a big town
so it's pretty far out there and the
detention when we paid he was like ah
it's this mark uh divide by four i trust
you do the calculation yeah yeah yeah
yeah it was clearly like a community
driven like little place right yeah yeah
yeah i mean it was cool but like yeah it
was cool i was just gonna say that
longer to
you know those japanese people they're
like you know connor's probably the
first white person they've seen like in
the flesh
like a beacon in there yeah i didn't
remember yeah like reflecting off of you
sometimes it's flattering because you're
like you're like oh maybe they're
checking me out or maybe they're just
staring at me because they don't know
the [ __ ] i am
it's like but i can pretend like it's
the first and then i'm like i must be
just so attractive that they can't stop
staring at me
i don't think it's that no i'm sure
they're looking at you like a rare
animal
i was like whoa
that's kind of cool that's like a shiny
worm pool in pokemon it's like wow
that's like a shiny photo that's weird
wow
i don't really want to put you in my
team but wow
that is that is something yeah
yeah i don't know it's really i don't
know sometimes it's chill sometimes it's
flattering because like
me
no pictures yeah oh god guys guys
see in here really
like but yeah i don't know it's fun it's
it's it's f it's like it's fun and it's
annoying it depends on the mood how
tired you are exactly right you can like
learn to embrace it yeah yeah yeah i i'd
say like 90 of the like if they don't
actively like
kick us out or say no or like cause any
issues i don't give a [ __ ] if they stay
i'm like whatever it's chill i get it i
would stare too yeah like if we were in
the middle of nowhere in [ __ ] wales
and like some japanese people walked in
i'd like whoa
what are you guys doing here yeah yeah
definitely are you lost yeah
do you need do you need help like
tokyo is that way
this isn't london
we're a long way from texas
where else do you want to travel outside
of tokyo because you've only just been
in tokyo you kind of went to osaka but
you didn't really get to explore it much
so go back to nara and feed the deer
um i want to trace your footsteps yeah i
want to go to hokkaido because i hear
the food is really good dude yes you've
never been max food yeah yeah bro you
don't even know you don't even know
and i want to go to a uh ryokan
i mean yeah oh yeah yeah that's a must
that's a mouse
yeah yeah yeah really really good ones
yeah it sucks because you can pay a lot
of money and it can be mid you can pay
like the same amount of money it could
be like the most insane amazing ryokan
ever so so if you don't like it the
first time i wouldn't say don't write it
off just because you've had one like if
you ever have one mid one it literally
just depends
and like some of them are insane some of
them are
overpriced yeah yeah yeah melin told us
that i don't know died has told us that
melon forced you to buy some premium
strawberries
were they worth it she loves strawberry
you love strawberries did i buy premium
strawberries well you went strawberry
picking right yeah
well they weren't that expensive
i mean they can be though have you
bought any of the expensive ones
i think the most expensive strawberries
i bought were like nine bucks so how
many
for like
nine
that's quite a lot yeah one dollar a
store so good strawberries are so good
here when they're in season and you're
that's your favorite right you're
obsessed with strawberries see okay they
were already one of my favorites when i
lived in the states but like
strawberries in the states kind of suck
yeah because they're like hollow
they're hard and they're kind of sad
yeah cut one open
well it's just gonna be a [ __ ] like
nothing
it's just not nothing but it's there's
like a little bit of space in there and
it's like not just like an air pocket
yeah there's something really what the
[ __ ] is going on in the u.s how do you
even do that and it's not juicy i mean
i'm sure there's some strawberries that
are juicy but i
once if you get like a carton of
strawberries from the supermarket you
can expect them to just be sour hard and
yeah so you never get like good ones in
america
you must do because you like
strawberries all right
where'd you get your lovely strawberries
from that [ __ ] there
i like strawberries but usually like
oftentimes i would have to eat it with
like a little bit of nutella
because it's like missing that like
extra sweetness
like you put whipped cream on it to get
that bit of sweetness so like in the
states i love strawberries on things
yeah but in japan i remember i tried
doing the nutella thing it's way too
sweet right yeah yeah yeah the
strawberries here are so like succulent
and
juicy and sweet yeah and oh my god [ __ ]
it already
it is so good i'm gonna miss it it's
already out of season i miss it already
i wanted to buy like those luxury like
fruit gift boxes to bring today oh yeah
yeah
problem is
uh strawberries are not in season
anymore yeah so they don't have any of
like the super nice good ones
is that why you asked me what my
favorite fruit is
okay i was just like why didn't you
bring my my favorite fruit because i do
i guess luxury bananas aren't a thing i
guess that's just like the peasants
that's a jojo fan dream dude
wait what did you say i said strawberry
as well and emily was like nice choice
and like they only sell like they sell
some kind of like premium bananas but it
was like in a single you can get like
premium like watermelon that's your
favorite right i chose warm milk i can't
just buy the watermelon
fruit and then i was like damn it what
do i do oh maybe i'll get like something
shareable
well
that's the thing i didn't i ended up not
getting anything because i saw a box of
cherries for like two hundred dollars
and i just walked out
two hundred dollars for a box of
cherries how many
there were cherries just
bunch of cherries the golden
giant cherry
i could have gotten because they were
they were selling like mini watermelon
for like 50 bucks oh yeah yeah oh i
could get joey watermelon but then for
the strawberries they were only selling
these like premium strawberries that
were like single packed yeah and i'm
like i can't just give one strawberry
no you definitely should have that'll be
hilarious
is the square
watermelon thing a thing yeah definitely
oh i've never seen the square
watermelons they're not edible no they
are aren't they no they're not edible
they must be no they're absolutely
what's the [ __ ] point in making them
not edible why would they make
they are the boys they looked it up on
google and they were like yeah they're
not edible people just buy them for
decoration no i've definitely eaten
water
i mean i'm googling this right now
they're just like a watermelon this just
has a funny shape oh it's like it's like
a [ __ ] minecraft interesting fact
emily can you can you give a source to
back it up
i mean i it was quite a what the [ __ ]
yeah this one says square watermelons
which are harvested while still unripe
are not edible and are purchase
generally as ornaments see what the [ __ ]
did i eat
someone like a regular watermelon that's
obviously shaped out yeah do you fall
asleep because my whole thing is that
like i like i do enjoy watermelon i do
find the shape really annoying yeah like
it's it's kind of like the round shirt
yes i'm trying to store a balloon
somewhere it's like it doesn't really
like pack well into the fridge so why
why would they have square watermelons
if they're not edible then i don't know
japan i don't know why why is why is the
kernel for christmas [ __ ]
like [ __ ] play minecraft once and
it's because the colonel looks like
santa
can i confess the other reason why i
ended up not getting the fancy fruit
i was terrified that you guys would
taste it and you'd be like yeah it just
tastes like a strawberry
but you would never you never get to you
never get to get the highs without the
lows right yeah yeah okay okay here's
how they taste the difference is there a
difference i don't know
because here's the thing i have actually
because strawberry is my favorite fruit
i have
bought a single strawberry once for five
dollars
um and it was like one of those like
giant strawberries yeah and i saw it and
i'm just like i gotta try it man yeah i
i gotta try i'm just like it's it was
like it was like it was a strawberry
like
kind of like it was it was like massive
it was like that big yeah kind of like
that that's a pretty big size of a
strawberry so it was about the size of
like three strawberries packed together
it was like five dollars i was like i
gotta try it
it was just a strawberry it was a very
very good strawberry it was just like
high like
the the volume of it was [ __ ] massive
i've never taken such a big fight on the
single strawberry but it of the
strawberry what did you expect like the
most
the moment you bit into it your balls
explode
you just come yeah yeah
that's it i i went to a bar the other
day and uh in this bar it was like a
small bar
and there was a strawberry seller at the
bar right so he brought strawberries for
everyone what is this like a jrpg it's
like the productions just hitting the
ball
she was in the bar and i walked in i was
there and he was just like yeah everyone
he wants to give all the people at the
bar strawberries all right so
it was a whole pack and they were big
yeah they were [ __ ] big yeah and i
was like all right i mean i just had a
big dinner but i guess i could eat a
strawberry yeah they gave me like five
in a bowl and i i was like jesus christ
i feel like matt stone where's this bar
i don't know if he's there every night
though yeah emily's just going to count
i'm like i'm not hungry so i eat one and
then they're like you have to you'd
finish them all it's it's like root
strawberries
and i'm like
like you said like this [ __ ] big one
of the strawberries are [ __ ] giant
yeah they're free yeah it was fun
i was i was but you ever watched matilda
no you've anyone watched matilda the
movie no [ __ ] sake dude it's like a
british it's like no it's american it's
but it's roll down so it's wrong roll
down something i don't know a [ __ ]
thing i think rodell
was british
right no yeah he is british yeah but the
matilda movie would uh with danny devito
uh is is american you know there's a
scene where where they forced the kid to
like eat all this chocolate cake oh yeah
yeah yeah i remember that yeah and
that's what it felt like i was like oh
he's so it's delicious but i'm so full
oh
i don't know like yeah it would have
been your like [ __ ] heaven though
yeah yeah that was me strawberry picking
with me lean we ate so many that like
we were so full maylene was like i'm
nauseous and then the very nice
strawberry farmer guy came up and was
like oh i got some white and pink straw
here you go do you like the white ones
yeah do you like the white ones they're
cute i prefer the red ones yeah the
white ones don't really have much taste
it looks sick it's like a like a shiny
pokemon it's yeah it's like a dragon
fruit it looks so cool but it doesn't
taste like anything yeah
anyway i don't know what i was gonna say
i thought you're gonna say something
like
i was i was being like yeah what do i
need what do i what can i add to white
strawberries i don't know they look like
a ssr drop of strawberries i guess
have you ever found much inspiration for
your videos being here i have really yes
i have oh [ __ ] okay okay okay okay
you're gonna
uh
tell
on them yet i i've started have you
actually i thought you were okay the
other day you were complaining you're
like i can't work
when
what day was this like like five days
ago show me the recipes ago yeah it it's
been like really busy because we're like
trying to get our life together do you
have your gaming chair
is that the reason why you can't work
because you don't have a game said he
can't work cause he doesn't have a good
chance yeah i can sit on the chair just
fine right
now you say that as if dinus looks at
the chair and he's like what do i do
i put my back i can sit on the chair
just fine but
it's also like
lately i've had to like wake up early
for stuff like your appointments yeah so
then i have to go to bed early
right wow you get used to it yeah
now it's like you have a schedule yeah
japan kind of got me off the degenerate
hours sleep schedule
commitments we need to do yeah geeks
possibly like emily turn up here at 9
a.m
i get to like midnight and i'm like [ __ ]
man i'm way past my bedtime people rely
on us for a schedule now yeah like you
wake up at like [ __ ] one and that's
like half the day gone yeah wake up like
50 slack messages i'm like
oh my god how many do i have to reply to
now but uh yeah like what was your sleep
schedule before you moved to japan then
was it like degenerate i would go to bed
at like four oh my god and i'd wake up
at like
10. because i'm 11. we used to play a
lot of league before you moved
uh and i would be like it's like 3 p.m
here she'll probably send like 5 a.m in
the u.s and i'll be like yeah you want
to play league no yeah
right away
i'll be like all right
all right cool you have to play tft
again yeah we were like addicted to tft
but these boys right never play that
don't ever try it i don't
get tft team fortress 2.
[Laughter]
explain explain tft it's the best your
ability yeah try to sell tft to us oh my
god i've played it once and i'm just
like i do not get this
i'm sorry
uh tft is a game in league of legends
yes
uh i'm a league player by the way i just
don't understand auto chess i'm not a
league player it's a gridlock
you get characters you buy it what is it
similar to i don't know what game is
similar to
no he's not going to help you
yeah yeah got a
manager gold every round and you try to
build the strongest team you can
by buying characters and leveling them
up so it's like balloons tower defense
sure i don't know yeah
it sounds like balloon style i like it
because it's chill and like how can you
get toxic playing a cute little i don't
know i get i can get toxic
yeah i know yeah but that's just yeah
that's true don't don't don't make any
games
i'm sure some people can find a way
i don't know it's fun though it's pretty
chill it's a good game to like chat with
because you kind of like it's pretty
cheap i'm not gonna lie i deemed no
information
so i can't even be like yeah
it's it's kind of like it's literally
like i mean the best way to describe to
you is that like it's a gacha roll
constantly sold literally it is
literally like imagine okay you are
literally a gacha players to manage
their wallet and and the the interest of
the economy to make sure that you can do
it
you know like
every every every turn you get five
choices right and then you have x amount
of gold yeah and you can buy some of the
characters but it'll mean you have less
gold now then get your credit card
promise you can't add money the only way
you can add money is by winning
fights
and getting a streak of winning or
losing right or no no
or you get like interest so you save
money right but the get your part is
that like you can you can if you're like
all right i have 50 gold
i think i can get this one character
within 20 gold if i don't do it i'm
broke and my game is ruined so you start
rolling
every time you refresh it costs two
money so you get like stuff like so it's
like bloons tower defense if you could
pick your unit every time yeah and then
like let's say you get three of the same
tower yeah it evolves so the and then if
you want to evolve it to level three
which is like the max one you have to
get like
two level uh three level two so you just
get nine total right right right and the
more you take it's shared amongst all
the other players so if you all go for
the same balloons tower defense
character
if if someone else is going for it as
well the odds of you getting it when you
re-roll is lower so imagine gacha
players where if god got the ssr
now you have way less chance of getting
the ssr oh [ __ ] so there's like a
strategy to like all right if i want to
[ __ ] gone over i don't need this
character but i'm so rich that i can buy
up this character to [ __ ] with god right
and make sure god can't get it i can
definitely see how that can become toxic
yeah it's great yeah it's really
frustrating because there's no
communication so when you see another
player buying all the [ __ ] you need and
they clearly don't need it you're like
if i can sell units right now the
economy is crashing because of you
it's fun though yeah and there's a lot
of down time because it's automatic so
when your turn is over you kind of don't
do anything for like a minute or two
minutes you can just watch the battle
yeah so you can kind of like tour you
can type you can send messages it's
pretty that's my problem with like
playing like i guess
multiplayer intense competitive games
it's not like
i'm like also like playing with friends
because i'm that guy who's just like
[ __ ] at multitasking uh when i'm playing
a competitive game yeah right because
like me playing league with friends is
just just me [ __ ] like just dumbed
out i i do not hear anything i hear
pings and that's it
i think the good thing about tft i'm
sorry i know i'm selling it here but i'm
just trying to give reasons to why i
enjoy the game
you can put as much like i have to pee
you can keep talking but i have to pee
i'm sorry
today's episode is sponsored by counter
side right guys
guys counter side is a mobile game made
for anime fans which is hopefully you
watching this anime podcast developed by
korean developer studio bisar this is an
rpg game where you take the role of a
ceo and assign counters soldiers and
mechs to fight against unknown monsters
in order to protect the world all
characters look stunningly gorgeous with
the live 2d graphics and the bgm is
carefully crafted just like the story
you can experience a rich in-game story
that is just as good as any other anime
games out there in addition to the
counter classes such as soldier mechanic
and ship stimulates users dreams so you
can maximize the fun by playing with
various concepts you can even
participate in real-time pvp events
which i would
if the boys were with me and look this
may be a gutchy game but they are coming
down with the generosity to commemorate
their launch they're coming out with an
event to give you 160 free gacha that's
a lot of gotcha and you can use coupon
code cs global 2022 for all these free
gifts on screen thank you to
countersight for sponsoring us today
back to the video the thing i like about
tft right i know i i i'll stop talking
about it because i know it's resident
sleeper it makes people [ __ ] bored to
death
i'll just gush about it a little bit
right the thing i like about it is that
you can put as much
like
multitasking and like thinking as you
want i feel like we'll me you and dadas
all play the game slightly different
right like daidus literally does not
give a [ __ ] what anyone else is doing he
literally is like i like this team i'm
gonna go for it no matter what and he
builds it every single time every single
game and like normally loses because
you're supposed the idea is that you're
supposed to like strategize around
what's going on changing adapt yeah and
then i feel like you're like kind of in
the middle where it's like you like
comps and you kind of like swap around
and you kind of pay attention to what's
going on and then like if you really
really want to like focus i can't do
this very well but like people you'll
watch them play the game they're
literally flicking between every single
player and seeing what they're buying in
real time and buying like accordingly
yeah they'd probably be good stock
traders if they yeah
something
productive
you know like the you probably need like
[ __ ] five screens just yeah every
every enemy all at once right
it's it's really like hard because you
have to like
learn
to like not be attached to anything in
that game like if you like a team and
you're like oh i'm building this perfect
team
if you're really good at the game you
can be like [ __ ] it we're starting again
let's get rid of this team let's get
another one start rolling let's not get
you rolling right i mean that's how you
win though right i don't know that's
that's the most awful part of gacha
though you got to get emotionally
attached you've got to get emotionally
touched otherwise why would i throw down
my credit card luckily in this you have
to spend money except except for on
skins where they charge you like
egregious amounts for skins
you'll have these little stupid [ __ ]
things in the game that are like your
avatar it's like 20 bucks for one gacha
roll of to get one not ten like one
i did a gacha roll to get ten eggs which
all contained one it was like it was
like a hundred bucks
for a ten roll what [ __ ] and i got
mugged off i got [ __ ] nothing good
yeah so jesus christ yeah so you know
so he basically just paid for a 100 game
i should weigh more than a hundred
dollars
i spent i've spent over like two grand
on league i'm not proud of saying that
but geez emily's probably spent two
grand on luck's skin so that's not true
i have those bot friends who's your main
the eagle classic
i have a luxe sugar daddy she literally
did you know that meme of the of the
girls going honey it's time for your 4
p.m dick fun
i edited it where it's me and dardis
yeah
honey there's a new lux skin out
i can't believe you don't buy your own
skins
i don't believe it can't believe it the
audacity wow i buy other people's skins
too yeah you probably buy them the [ __ ]
ones
the luxe ones are like five five hundred
dollars for like a fancy particle effect
no they're not
you're guessing your main is lux then
yes she literally only plays that
i like syndra too
i literally like literally joey knows
those guys i know these characters
unfortunately none of them are in arcane
joey this is
all those [ __ ] k-pop videos yeah and
all the head ties
yeah i like i like luck she's cute
why'd you like looks um she has a
magical girl skin of course of course of
course now it makes sense when i first
started playing league i was like
flipping through the characters who do i
like i like annie at first world because
she's easy to play yeah yeah and then i
i tried playing caitlyn i liked her too
right but they're all kind of the same
of like a lot of them are like oh i want
to be powerful i'm so strong and
powerful
and then lux is really cute she's like
she's like positive a magical girl i
hate her voice
she's just like she's just like a bubbly
nerd and it was so endearing so
basically she's just you yeah yeah
yeah for real she's just like
emily has the habit of getting really
attached to characters that are just her
yeah yeah you know like
like torah from fruit basket is like a
favorite how about you assume that she
doesn't have a like
if she
she doesn't swear or has like a loose
side or whatever how dare you assume
that emily i'm kidding
she's a whole human being
speaking of a fruit basket what anime
are you into what are you watching i
love spy family
i've been catching up with jiu jitsu
okay funny enough it was really funny
the last right now i'm on episode 16
17. what just okay yeah yeah yeah but uh
i remember at the very beginning the
very beginning of this episode
uh this is kind of when they sort of go
into panda's backstory and also the
robot guy yeah oh that fight yeah yeah
and at the very beginning of the episode
i was like man it's been like 16
episodes but like i'm still not super
invested in this show yeah maybe like
maybe it's just not my thing we'll see
right and i watched it and like this one
was just so
cute and like emotional and like at the
end the episode was done daisy was like
oh no i'm crying a little bit and then
and then i turned around with like tears
screaming
oh my god so cute
so i like it so you think it's better
than okay
yeah for a while i was like you hear
that you hear
if a show takes like 16 episodes for me
to like feel something yeah
i thought it was better than that
no no no no also you're about to get
like the best part yeah yeah it's gonna
get better that's the thing i i don't
like it when someone's like oh it'll get
better after like 55 episodes wait i i
like sukuna right away literally calling
out everyone
like the first episode
i think it's because like i'm not built
for shonen
like
what are you built for what are you what
are you built
[Laughter]
what are you built for i don't want to
be crucified but like i think because i
love watching like
funny like goofy
anime that when i was watching jutsu
kaisen live i didn't really care that
much about the fights like they're like
sick but like it's a shonen fight yeah
yeah also like i feel like yuji's just
like every other shonen pro tag that
i've ever seen i'm sorry the kaiser fans
are quaking right now dude
she's right you know
what the [ __ ] no dude what the [ __ ]
folks now she's right
no like like i remember when i first
started watching i was like i don't get
what is so special about this show like
it's not that's exactly how i felt about
it
you know what is this [ __ ] slander
going on over here it is it is it is
like it is i said this when i made like
a shout and tear this it is 100 the
hmong readers because i've heard it gets
[ __ ] incredible which i'm sure it
does i really like that hungary to say
this literally allison was like on my on
my side of things where i was like
okay and then like he went off to read
the manga and he was like [ __ ] i hate to
admit that shonen fans were right but
they're right and i'm like if if alan
can admit that i'm like okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah i i absolutely love
the first season i thought it was one of
the best shonen that we had in the world
my favorite moments like the parts that
i like the most in jujutsu kaisen for
like
the goofy moments the goofy moments like
goofy little then you must love like
toto right total his name yeah yeah the
the guy who's obsessed with him
no i don't like him
what he's weird i don't like him
he's literally like the best dude i
don't like he's confusing okay well okay
give it a few episodes he gets even
better okay
how do you know mikey what the [ __ ] he's
so charming and like the robot guy i was
like and he's whatever he's just like a
robot guy okay yeah and then they got
into like his backstory yeah and like at
the very end when like it's just the
cute little moments he has with his
friends yeah yeah and now they're like
to depend on him and i was like oh
that's so sweet
but all the fighting stuff
so you just like your mind just goes
whenever they like they start fighting
yeah right so you just want like you
just want like the pandas just like [ __ ]
and fart everywhere and then like that's
that's like amusing man pete is so cute
so basically if if if you if there was
like a spin-off of jesus christ and
where just went over panda's stuff yeah
just be like oh not just all over that
[ __ ] like just them being homies
like gojo he's okay
so basically if there was a slice of
life spin-off of jesus christ where all
the characters are just kind of hanging
out
bro emily would see like [ __ ] jesus
on the cross be like yeah
like the little the ending
or when judas and him
we're all together panda's bringing like
a scarf and earmuffs and it's all cute
and they're all just being friends are
we watching the same [ __ ] show like
what are you watching here like what are
you getting out of this emily's gonna
get to the [ __ ] hanami flight where
it's just like like spoilers you know
when it when it's just like as [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah
it's the fight where all the cool [ __ ]
happens yeah yeah yeah be like hey
when are they gonna go shopping
you literally want them to like just
like animate a full series of just like
the ed well you know it's just you know
where like they go shopping and
everything like that they have all the
bags all the bags give me the back story
i think that's why i love spy family so
much it's just like goofy shenanigans
yeah the steaks are not high yeah so you
don't lower your
steaks
i just don't want to be stressed out
what the actual [ __ ] emily what are you
talking
you mean like giving a [ __ ] about like
the plot
no i give a [ __ ] about the plot but like
we're spy family so you don't like stuff
that makes you stressed out not too
stressed out you watch like uh uncut
gems or um
uh what's the other one that they did um
[ __ ] is the other rod pads and good time
you watched that one oh daddy's just
watching are those movies yeah
why is it different why is it different
because shows are so much longer i don't
i'm stressed out for a while it's not
all like [ __ ] edging like there's
like there's parts where like there is
tension and it gets resolved i mean yeah
i i don't know maybe just like it's like
i don't just encounter it's a movie what
are you talking about
it's so weird how like you're so
committed because it's in a show form
but then when you look at the individual
scenes you're not committed at all
it's like i don't care about this i'm
not committed who's that one character
with the blue hair he pisses me off the
long haired guy and which show did you
skysen well oh the the like the animal
dude oh the one on the other like school
from kyoto
oh
that guy i really like the episode where
he got his ass beat that was funny
but well anime do you like then if you
don't like tell them
yeah fruits yeah
it should be called mid basket
that's what it is
i like when an anime is just a good time
and it feels good like freeze basket is
like you've watched
this really dramatic
i really enjoyed my dress-up darling
that was really
cool why are you grilling me i just want
to know what else that's too high stakes
apparently okay wait you know what
dramatic show i really liked actually
fine ed
but that also kind of took a while to
that first
argument both oh okay
it's good that's good of course so wait
wait that's way more like horrible than
that and that's like way more like
dramatic and traumatizing
what's going on this makes sense but the
build up is like cute slice of life but
juicy kaisen has build on you sound like
you sound like he's like you sound like
he needs like the cute slice of life to
like reel her in
like smack it sounds like giving the dog
medicine and like a slice of cheese it's
like take the dramatic pill take
what you're saying is you would be more
invested in the jesus kaisen scene if a
scene before they were shopping
no
yeah that's basically what you're saying
it's like okay okay okay and then bam
what about another scene in judicial i
really liked
when uh well that big guy was telling
mai to
he gave her a ticket to see that one
idol and like yeah
she was like pretending she didn't like
it that was cute
and you still don't like toto
literally the most minor scene in the
entire show is like yeah that that's the
that's the highlight you think about um
uh madoka magica i liked it
that was pretty [ __ ] dark yeah that
was that's like suffer porn the anime
but that's different what what about
this difference
there was fights in that is it is it
because madoka's wearing pink
no it's because it's magical girl that's
why yeah anything with magical girl
should just leave so if if
you see me show but it wasn't it i'd be
like
nothing about that was funny what no
like the joke got stale after one
episode i'm like okay she's dumb i get
it
[Laughter]
um i didn't see the second season of one
punch man but
you don't you don't need to you don't
need rhythm
[Music]
that's got action in it though yeah did
you did you enjoy the first season one
punch yeah i mean it's great
it is very good it is really good i love
like goofy stuff do you like death note
i did
but that also has tension i just you
just saw me misa you're like i am
invested
allow me to pay attention no that's not
true
are you are you telling me honestly that
when meesha came in death no they're not
throwing hands in death note
well so murder is okay as long as they
don't get physical
[Laughter]
i think i think psychological trauma is
fine physical trauma is a no-no mr kerfs
just doesn't get pushed
[Laughter]
how dare you adopt my life the greatest
showdown fights of all time the
fisticuff have you watched
like you to is
oh yeah yeah well yeah because of course
it's wholesome cute yeah yeah no [ __ ] i
think you just don't like fighting right
that's yeah that's it right no but she
likes one punch man that's different
she's not fighting that's that's that's
murder
okay so let me get this straight you
don't like fight scenes in anime where
you don't know if the main guy is going
to win or not
no
that's what it's sounding like i just i
like i like low stakes you know like you
know he's gonna be okay i thought i can
watch that's most anime
that's most anime fights true because
otherwise you would just and you're like
this in real life yuji literally died
well he came back but
the dude literally died the stakes are
high
wait oh yeah he does yeah
complete but i mean like we all knew he
was going to go
back is this some like childhood like
thing where you're like you just hate
like seeing
people fight in movies or something i
don't know
i mean yeah
i kind of get it because no i don't i
don't at all
i
oh you don't [ __ ] get it don't
pretend like you're just trying to be
nice don't you
i get it because sydney hates fights as
well unfortunately and i have to live
with that and i'm just like sydney look
at this amazing action scene and she's
like bro but like but like sex is just
cooperative fighting that's just like
she likes that song come on fight i just
want to show
uh have you seen bucky at all no oh my
god i just want to show you
because it's like ridiculous it's
everything it's everything emily hates
it's like ridiculous
[Laughter]
you should watch you should watch it
this is what they all look like
i like that
we don't like the muscles i love him i
love that emily's reacting as if you
showed her like gallbladder yeah yeah
it's literally just a bug
in one of the scenes one of the
characters can make like a demon face
with his back muscles
yeah and then everyone's like it's the
demon face oh [ __ ]
it seems like it seems like like a jojo
fan type of show
i was gonna ask have you seen jojo no i
have no idea why i don't know if i'd be
into it you know what you know what
twitter post i keep thinking of when i
hear jojo what what have you seen that
post that's like jojo fans be like oh my
god he's so hot ben proceeds to show me
the ugliest
he is literally one of the ugliest
characters
that is literally one of the characters
that's literally what he looks like
oh a rocky fan's quaking right now
i i don't know i mean i think you should
try jojo you might actually enjoy it
because it's really goofy yeah yeah it's
really really interesting
it's like so serious that it's like the
most goofiest thing in the world yeah
it's like imagine making like a fight
out of like someone holding in a fart
like that's like basically jojo fights
like it's it's it's like keep up like
how do you follow it though you start
with one i don't know just like i don't
know and then it's part three
and you just keep going in order but
like most of the memes are from one to
five at the moment because like no
nobody's read the manga really i mean
like yeah hardcore fans have but like
people only meme the anime stuff yeah
but like even like from like the first
episode you'll start recognizing memes
okay which is like kind of fun it's like
spot the meme it's like one of the most
famous memes is from episode one yeah to
be continued
there's like so many memes in episode
it's like a meme bingo yeah i was i was
thinking about joey memes i was like
that's not there's not a lot of part one
oh no wait a minute it's just been so
long since i've seen part one literally
most do memes
yeah yeah and then you can watch the
like the jojo music meme
you can watch it whatever you probably
think emily looks so lost right
it's
crazy memes i've seen and yet i still
don't know a single thing about the show
that's like most people though yeah
that's jojo in a nutshell
i could spoil the entirety of like a
part that hasn't been animated and
you'll probably be like i gained no
information from that whatsoever yeah
and you could probably still go
like one of the villains in one part is
the president of the united states of
america and they have to like resurrect
jesus christ to like help is it the
actual like president
yeah in the show yeah the action oh no
it's it's like the president in this
universe in the universe for a second i
thought colin's taking the piss and i
was talking about metal gear solid which
i'm just like
which is also like
a senator that's a senator by the way
i made it the [ __ ]
okay that's two metal gears games then
because like in one of the main games
i'm like the main uh the president is
like the bad guy as well yeah exactly
it's good it's good it's uh yeah you
should read it or watch it it's fun i'll
give it a shot um you should watch your
diet you know i just like complains
about everything don't want your
daughters he does he literally like will
watch one thing like oh [ __ ] actually
yeah we forgot
yeah we've got to ask what did his
favorite favorite anime was he's just
like yeah yeah he's just like a romance
anime he loves like dramatic romance so
like i like rom-coms yeah and he likes
the
the
romance anime that's like golden time
i like golden tone
is it like super dramatic and like
[ __ ] up stuff happens yes and he
probably likes it yeah but like he i
can't figure out what darius likes
because he'll tell me he likes one thing
and then he'll tell me some other stuff
and i'm like these are like completely
correlated
like i cannot figure you out they're
like oh this is [ __ ] i'm like what
that's like universally praised i mean
he said he's his favorite is clannad
he likes the drama right so like you'll
notice that if you ask him what his
favorite character is in like every show
he always picks the ones that everyone
hates not because he's trying to be a
contrarian but he just loves the
characters that cause problems i know i
know like me and me and dardis have
exactly the same taste with like romance
and he loves [ __ ] trashy romance and
like this is the spice he loves ichigo
100 that should tell you more than
like messy drama he loves what is it
nana yeah
that's good though that's a good mama's
a good choice i remember i remember when
i was a kid and i was trying to read
nana i was like what the hell is
happening
i'm too young for this
yeah it's definitely a mature show
exactly like
it definitely ain't a slice of life
comedy that's that's for sure i mean
it's kind of a slice of life but it's
like he loves things that i feel like
normal people would find soul crushing
um
yes
i like that as well i like those yeah
yeah i like the depressing shows yeah
that's like my dog magicka right
it's depressing but they're like oh
pretty colors yeah i certainly didn't
look at madoka magical and go oh magical
i was like oh what happened to madoka
magica did it just fall off
what do you mean did it end it ended it
really like years ago i watched
some guy i watched like the movies and
i'm gonna be honest i don't know what
the [ __ ] happened no dude i don't
understand that
i was i was like confusing as hell i was
like don't exist okay okay wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait
it ended at episode 12 or 13 there is no
oh i kept on watching and that's when i
was like what what happened i i watched
the movies i didn't know what happened
yeah i don't i didn't
i don't even think the creator of the
magic knows what happens okay because
for years i was so scared to say that
i'd watch the movie just in case people
ask me what happened yeah and i'd be
like
no but you're okay because literally
everyone who watched the movie doesn't
know i didn't know this because no one
talks about maybe everyone's the same
thing as me but they're like i don't
want to pretend like i'm the i don't
want to be the only one do you remember
what happened at the end of madoka
magica no
you have to bear in mind it's been like
2014. yeah don't remember that yeah yeah
but that's because the the ten episodes
leading up i'll be honest like what the
[ __ ] i watched all of madoka but i can
literally only remember like the one
scene where like mammy dies oh yeah i
mean that's that's
by the way
if you don't [ __ ] know that by now
you come on you should have watched
madoka magic yeah that's the scene that
just got like memed the [ __ ] up that's
what like made madoka explode but yeah
like there was technically a sequel
movie and everyone tries to forget that
it exists
um
it's i don't know why i don't even
remember if it was bad yeah it was it
was it was [ __ ] i'll just say it's [ __ ]
i'll go on a limb and i'll sort of [ __ ]
i'm sure there's like 10 madoka fans
that are like no it was a masterpiece
yeah i mean i watched it and it's like
it kind of like gave a plot twist and
then just ended and then uh they just
never do you remember this [ __ ] i i
literally for the life of me cannot keep
recall or like keep memories of shows
that i just were like huh well then i
just feel like
that just means they were mean
yeah i mean it wasn't even mid it was so
bad that i immediately
it was horrible you'd remember it wasn't
that horrible so it's me it was
confusing no no it was still like a two
out of ten like horrible for me it's
like zero out of ten right or like
hilariously zero out of ten yeah like
the like the room right you can't yeah
yeah that's like stays with you yeah but
it's like it's like someone had a vision
and they should have been stopped like
you know what i mean like yeah
i mean i mean like the madoka movie was
just really confusing that was pretty
much it i feel like that's 90 of anime
movies though
no no a lot of movies i i watched at
least when i started watching anime i
was like what the [ __ ] you mean anime
films based off tv shows like the ones
that continued or the ones that had like
parts that weren't like pokemon they
were very easy to follow
like what uh what's some other 2000s
shows that had movie spin-offs or movie
like sequel prequel things
or metal alchemists that had a movie
yeah that was the circus one right where
they went to the circus in the start
right that's all i remember and then
they went to the tower and there was a
dragon in the tower i remember that and
i don't remember that i don't remember
anything else
black butler no no wait full metal
alchemist yeah they were just like a
tower and there was a dragon in the
tower wait how okay how did you feel
about the black butler movie
uh oh the the book of atlantic yeah no i
mean that's like literally just like
covering a really simple part of the
plot where they're like there's a
there's like zombies on a boat yeah i'm
trying to think of confusing anime
movies and the only one that comes to
mind is evangelion yeah
okay
i haven't watched that because i heard
that was confusing madoka was one of
them
on the same level was like in the end of
ava where it's just like i don't know
what i i i maybe i'm completely talking
about my ass actually i just got like
research
this is a common occurrence on trash
taste i'm sorry
i do remember that we have to like talk
about him realizing that he's full of
[ __ ] that's true that's true i shouldn't
just make broad
broad statements that make no sense what
is my state where is my source i made it
the [ __ ] up
it's like every anime movie is confusing
did you watch
like they had like the season one right
yeah and then they had season two which
came out after it right yeah and then
the newest one was a remake yes no it's
a reimagining
see i hate whenever i do that i hate
when they do that wait so it's not even
the same
it's like the same show but it's like a
different timeline i don't know
supposedly i didn't finish it like the
ava movies yeah i don't know anyone who
watched season two of higashi except
like joe i did yeah but joey doesn't
count because he's yeah i don't know a
lot of people who watch season two
really i i could not see this
was good because you're not gonna
understand it unless you watch season
two so so so i watched season one yeah
but i watched it in english yeah and
that was a big mistake yeah because then
i went to watch season two which only
had japanese dub and it was such
whiplash for me at the time when i was
like
you have to get used to the voices it
was like because the the english version
of hikarashi is notoriously very bad it
is awful
you got like bad whiplash because i was
just like they don't know like the the
it was such because obviously they it
was so different yeah like that even
like the how the overall vibe of the
show right was so different because the
dub was so mid yeah
there you go
it was it was it wasn't it really wasn't
it really wasn't good so like going to
the japanese one was just like yeah the
whiplash is too strong and i couldn't
like get past the first episode yeah oh
wow but also i'll be honest i don't
really know what the [ __ ] was going on i
don't really know why
well because i pay attention but season
two literally explains everything that
happens yeah yeah yeah yeah so so lit
literally just explain [ __ ] as we're
going you know because that's the
fingernail or being one or does that
still see this yeah that's season one
yeah yeah yeah so basically it's like
season one is set up so that it's kind
of this like mystery plot line is it
really good
it's actually really good i should go
back and watch [ __ ] on jack
like so like the the way that the game
was originally set up was that like you
go through this like storyline with
multiple playthroughs but they don't
give you all the information and then
season two of the anime is like
oh well you've tried to figure out the
riddle here's the answer then they
explained everything that happens and
then you're like oh that totally makes
sense yeah so you literally just got
this you watch the season where you you
have every question and nothing's
answered you basically you basically
looked at the riddle and went well
there's no answer all right
maybe the groups i was in no one watched
it but i don't know yeah yeah probably a
bunch of other monkey okay and then
don't bother after season three like it
sucks well i heard the remake because i
said you might like it because it's just
the slice of life of all the characters
like yeah it's just like without like
the creepy myths what yeah
that was like seasonal what the [ __ ] is
the point part of the appeal though
that's that one they made like people
like emily
i don't want to see them killing each
other
i just want to see them going to the
pool and hanging out
they're just such cute little girls you
know
i just want to see them i liked it a lot
back when i was in middle school yeah
but i feel like when you're in middle
school you're kind of more of like a
little little edge lord yeah of course
you watch anything when you're in school
i don't think i would like it now if i
watched it again no i mean the only
reason i watched it was because i'm like
yo these cute girls are [ __ ] each
other oh
no
get on
like do you ever think about like how
anime starved you were when you were a
kid so like you would just consume
anything and sometimes you just kind of
welcome to my life you had no you had no
business being a 12 year old reading
this stuff but you kept going yeah when
you like watched like when you were like
yo anime's for adults let me put on the
first episode of elf and leaves well
that [ __ ] freaked me out when i was like
13. man did you watch that did you yeah
when i was i i think i watched like two
episodes and i was like dude literally
the opening scene is a severed arm and i
was like goated
i was like no i can't do it too much
it just felt like it was gory for the
sake of no no it completely was
completely aimed for kids well i just
like remember like so many [ __ ] 13.
yeah yeah i just remember like so many
[ __ ] you know that that image where
she's like animes for kids what's this
then and it's just it was like elvenly
it was it was the first episode of alfie
i'm just like
it's it's the most one of the most
immature anime to come out but you know
we it was framed as an adult anime but
it was definitely i do when you were 14
you ate that [ __ ] this is literally like
i'm 13 and this is deep
you watched
no that's one of my favorites that's
fantastic yeah [ __ ] no one's watched
that goddamn show i know i'm so sad it's
so good have you watched it gone uh i
haven't actually it's the one of the
only wow it's one of the most underrated
initiations yeah it's so goddamn good
that's one of my favorite anime of all
time oh really yeah hell yeah
yeah what are some of your other
favorites
i don't know what we're doing
so we've established card captor sakura
fruits basket clan ad yeah good taste
oh
did you watch it nope why not
what is it jobless reincarnation is the
english title what is going on
connor's the one who brought up
maybe you might like mushroom tension
maybe i don't know i mean it's not
really the same
that's not other than they're both
yeah yeah that's not really like
conor super is definitely more
light-hearted than meshuggah tensei i
don't know do you recommend do you
recommend it do i add it to my watch
list yeah it's like that's like saying
like yeah sakamotodeska is a lot like
log horizon because they both wear
glasses
it is actually because he's always very
good at whatever he does
that's the name you gotta watch you
gotta watch sakamoto that's amazing one
that's actually a banger you love that
that's like right that's goofy
oh is that the guy who's just like okay
oh my god i would like that you would
love that you would like that
that's a good show how much like time do
you have to watch anime nowadays then do
you still watch it a lot i am actually
this year i'm trying to culture myself
by consuming more
so that's what i've been doing so what
are you guys what are you starting with
well well okay this is not anime related
good start good stuff
ago two nights ago
had me wash holes
oh yeah i really liked it what the [ __ ]
does that have to do with your anime
culture no no no culturing in general
just like catching up on stuff wholesale
i don't think holes is like a classic
movie oh really wait holes is the one
with that
yeah
that's not that's it's not like uh
they're not like
they're departed godfather shawshank
redemption halls
do not [ __ ] ask us what the classic
movies are i liked it
what else movies do you suggested
well i watched the lord of the rings
trilogy
i wasn't a huge fan of the whole movie i
i didn't even watch the second or third
i was so bored on the first really
i like it it's not the same it's not so
wait it's let's go back what anime are
you playing yeah yeah oh well now i'm
trying to keep up more with the current
anime
i've been watching like spy family and
also because i'm like i'm seeing it
everywhere and i'm like well i have to
watch it yeah like you hear everyone
talking about it nowadays especially
you can you can talk to japanese people
for like at least 10 minutes if you just
know like the names of like five atoms
if you just be like i like spare family
that's like an hour conversation right
there yeah yeah yeah exactly i do i i
did what i see a lot of detective conan
yeah and i did like watching detective
conan when i was younger yeah back in
like middle school but there's so many
episodes you only need to watch like
three episodes of detective conan's be
like yeah i get it i get it we talk
about it
let's be honest there's like it ain't
that dude it gets really good though
teenager in kid body
what else you need to know about
detective code all i'm gonna say is it
gets better in the manga
shut the [ __ ] up it does god you don't
have to watch the movies just no wrong
no no trust i see tokyo revengers
everywhere
is it good it starts really strong kind
of
gets [ __ ] it's okay yeah
what else what else
i got to say
i finished demonstrating
why because i tried reading it and it i
thought it was really ugly well yeah
[Laughter]
actually no even 10 year olds you watch
and you can't even handle attack on
titan yeah it's different no it's yeah
it is
a lot worse
it's different okay i feel like horror
is different you like you know
no no no so you think you want you
because you're expecting it like yeah
you're like yeah people are gonna die
i'm ready for this well then why don't
you go into attack on titan expecting
people to die because
i don't know
i just never go did you enjoy like
another then did you watch another back
in the day another yeah the one that was
literally just like gore amv yeah yeah
no okay okay i don't like gory stuff
like whole animals
you watch higarashi
i was in middle school that's gory as
[ __ ] i was in middle school i could
handle it back then
child you could handle it better than
adult you
you're like
benjamin button
when i was a kid i was like i wanna look
at all dog edgy stuff yeah like
i i like creepy things
and now i'm just slenderman i'm an adult
i'm like man i just want to like enjoy
the stuff i'm confused
yeah i feel like ever since we started
talking about anime we've just put emily
on like the podium it's just like tell
me your taste
objection objection based on like the
stuff i've told you you kind of get a
feel for like what might you do yeah
yeah yeah yeah like
if i see like an anime like wrap up
video
i'm like alright what am i interested in
and it's like
a new goofy anime haha funny laughs and
i'm like i'm going to watch that one
[Laughter]
it's like like uh what was the last one
like not nakatora did you like that one
you
uh comey can't communicate got boring
for me it looked boring it it got kind
of boring wow you just called out like
every single comey simple i'm sorry it
looks kind of boring very cute watch you
don't talk though just open your mouth i
tried to
it looks like one of those shows it
would be really endearing for like six
episodes and i'd be like i kind of feel
like i've seen everything
it's okay
shut the [ __ ] up
like like shut the [ __ ] up
is it bad that i can see i can see a
premise and like the kind of like just
passing scenes and i can be like i can
already tell what this experience is
going to be and i'm fine not having to
be fair
if if i were to come to comey sons
defense there is like a romantic
development that gets really [ __ ]
good
what's that one romance anime i got
invested and then gave up on in high
school
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah i tried getting into
hurry me i couldn't do it
mia or me gets boring off the like
volumate god so many of these like i
know they're all different but in my
mind they're just they occupy the same
space of show yeah yeah yeah horomia and
uh
they just seem like the same show yeah
they're just they're right
yeah they're just
i think like what really separates dress
up darling is literally just the main
characters yeah you know they they just
they actually felt like really
interesting characters that weren't just
like your typical you know
happy-go-lucky romance characters a lot
of the time to be fair though i'm like
catching up with i've like caught up
with the manga for
dress-up darling and the latest volume
was kind of boring and i was like oh
please don't hurry me up this [ __ ]
please i beg of you don't get boring
yeah because because the thing about
praying yeah because the thing about
things like
like nagato especially in like komisan
it's just like it's kind of the same
show just like with a different gimmick
like oh this time the girl can't speak
and you know it's it's the story of like
you know it's it's a it's a fun
happy-go-lucky story but the girl can't
speak or like nagatorio she's the bully
and then after like around seven volumes
that i think everyone starts to realize
it's like oh all right i'm not sure if
we can milk out this one
any further
sure i want to know if you like because
i feel like it it has a few things uh do
you like re-zero
i haven't seen it oh
okay why do you think emily will like it
i don't know there is some gore in there
obviously but there's also the trashy
romance aspect of the subaru doesn't
look interesting to me
like another loser and attraction you
you do that
you're gonna do that and then you'll
literally like watch fruit baskets and
then be like
i was just like you know i don't want to
be like that that [ __ ] who's just
like yeah it's just like you just don't
get it but like
[Laughter]
you don't have it you don't have a deep
enough intellect to understand raise
your hand
high enough
i mean like one of the great things
about subaru is that he's passed off as
like a loser and attracts super then he
gets a lot of development okay like
actually like has to deal with the fact
that like he's cringe and like yeah yeah
yeah yeah the whole story is about how
yo bro you cringe like you you you
[Laughter]
that's literally the show yeah i would
consider i'll consider watching yeah
you'll like it and then because i know
that you'll you'll have a lot to say
about it that's why i think you should
watch it yeah both i think i think
you'll have a lot to say and you'll go
off on one i can see it's being one of
those shows where you'll just go off i
just want you to watch the show just so
i could hear your opinion yeah because i
know you're going to have such a strong
opinion it's definitely going to be a
discussion yeah yeah you should watch it
because the thing is you have this much
to say about jiu-jitsu and i was just
like i didn't even have this much
seriously
when i talk about anime from a living i
was just like i remember like when he
said
anime list and then emily went off about
toradora for like 40 minutes and then i
ended with like i like it yeah i just
was like it's good
what toridora's like aos dude huh
is like soa for me
[ __ ] off anyway
[ __ ] off dude
don't wash your like silver spoon or
some [ __ ] what do you like hey it's a
good shot
take that back take that back
all right well emily i'm sorry that
we've been bullying you for the past 40
minutes about anime tasting no i think i
think you know i we're all good friends
so i think it was uh the right time to
bring up your taste
and although although i'm not really i'm
not really warranted i just occasionally
just be like yeah [ __ ] just just can't
have a little bit of spices still i had
a bit of a spice in there you know but
thank you so much for coming on did you
have fun i had a lot of fun of course
you did where can people find you
they can't find i have to burp
just do a
mid-sentence i am
they can find me on youtube yes emory
too
uh you can also find me on twitch at
emory yt yeah and you can find me on
instagram at emerychu with twou's on
twitter awesome oh and twitter and
reachuit sorry there's so many different
handles it's just everything that's
taken from i've never seen you like con
this is like the most you've
concentrated this entire podcast you're
like uh you can find me here and here
you're reading that off like a twitch
donation
but yeah uh hey look at these patrons
look at all these lovely pretty diamonds
who's your favorite they're they're
right there
right there right there
i like him too yeah or her i don't know
hey if you like to support the show go
to our patreon patreon.com also follow
us on twitter send us some memes on the
subreddit and if you hate our face
listen to us on spotify and go check out
emily's stuff links in the description
yeah thank you yeah thank you very much
i hope you had a good time i had a great
time thank you and we'll see you guys
next time
[Music]
you